together
know the fire alarm test is planned but
should the fire alarm sound please leave
the room at your nearest exit and meet
at the front of the grandstand
please raise your hand if you wish to
sleep
and stay seated while speaking
please wait until the boom microphone is
brought to you
you will not be heard on the live stream
otherwise
we're masked at all times
you are seated
keep points short
and i ask members not to repeat points
that have already been raised
and voting will be
by a show of hands
could we now have apologies for absence
please
i've had apologies from
councillor foden
councillor jay pedreck councillor l
pederek councillor pitt cancer
rollerston councillor 2 and councillor
jenks
thank you sarah
item 2
the minutes of the annual council 28th
of july 21 could i have a proposal for
those minutes being accepted
councillor connect propose a seconder
councillor jewhurst
could i have a show of hands all in
favor
that looks pretty well unanimous
thank you
no uh anybody against
any
abstentions
okay
sorry about that
can we raise your hands just so we can
count please
for your extensions
carried
thank you very much
now i'd like to go on to item three
some announcements
councillors this is my first address to
members of the council since my
inaugural speech at the annual council
in may
i would like to introduce
formerly though we've had to leave my
chaplain for the year father nick debney
he's the vicar of saint luke's church
milburn
welcome and thank you to him
during this year my wife gene will act
as my consort and my charity which is
very close to my family's hearts is
alzheimer's research
i want
i believe that it's an important
opportunity to take stock on the last
two years
i want to thank my member colleagues for
their work in communities throughout the
pandemic
and for supporting local organizations
through funds like their locality and
community funds
to deliver vital services for some of
the most vulnerable members of society
i have received nominations from some of
the people who have gone above and
beyond for the local communities
and i've written to them personally to
thank them for their efforts
there is still an opportunity to
nominate someone from a local community
or voluntary sector organization
until next month support for residents
businesses and communities throughout
the pandemic
it's been a big ask
but our frontline staff have been
delivering services day in day out
from the beginning of the pandemic we
their staff have stepped up to the rolls
worked long hours
initially many were doing it from their
dining tables or bedrooms
to make sure people received vital
support
grants
housing benefits
business loans
or helping people to come off the
streets into safe housing
the leader and the managing director
have asked me to announce that all staff
will be given an additional day's leave
this municipal year as a thank
thank you
as
fine as a thank you for the hours and
efforts they have put to help our
communities
so that they can spend some extra time
with their friends or their families or
simply a day to rest and recuperate
the pandemic has left an indelible
impact on all our lives
and i recently raised a flag in the
grounds of old ford house as a tribute
to the emergency services
who have been severely affected by it
in recognition of the impact of covid
across the district the loss of life
and the service provided by all in
support of individuals and communities
we intend to establish a covered
memorial in the grounds of old forward
house
councillors i know we all look forward
to emerging from the recent stressful
times
although i urge you all still to take
care and precautions ongoing
now in respect of business today
due to importance of the bradley lane
regeneration i'm going to change the
order of the agenda
and bring forward items 12 to 15 to be
taken after item nine
then we will go back to complete the
agenda with items 10 and 11.
we will now move on with the agenda
item four
do we have any declarations of interest
cannot see any hands raised
appears none
okay now we move on to
some public questions
and at the back of the room i think
there are some questioners
firstly i have
a questioner it was questioner madeline
but it's been replaced by questioner
rebecca
there is everyone's been given a
response regarding this question
from the leader
i would ask rebecca if she has a
supplementary she would like to ask one
supplementary per question
your answer to the first question that
madeleine who i am advocating for put in
uh the question was um
that you are aware of the coronavirus
act requirement of three legal
conditions to justify such a serious
decision as locking down the cambridge
local economies and limiting freedom of
the local citizens
she asked that you explain and justify
with supporting evidence lockdown and
lockdown restriction enforcement
decisions made by the team bridge
council during the 2020
um
restrictions and up to the current date
you've answered
that under direction to the secretary of
state
teen bridge council along with other
local authorities has worked to support
the communities
etc and that the council followed the
professional safety and public health
advice of those qualified and appointed
to provide that guidance
you've also stated that in devon on
matters of public health we've been
advised and supported by the director of
public health at devon county council
and you may feel it's more appropriate
to submit your questions to the county
council
my first point is that as teen bridge
district council you
serve team bridge constituents
and therefore this
is a question for you not devon county
council
you are voted in as public servants for
your constituents
and therefore passing the buck to devon
county council is not really a
satisfactory answer to this question
i have with me evidence of freedom of
information requests that show that
teen bridge was one of the least
affected areas
in
in great britain with the lowest number
of infections and cases
i have written for freedom of
information requests at the hospitals
and i was uh told by dereford
that
the amount of people that died in 2020
of the coronavirus alone
was five or less
you locked down the area on five or less
deaths last year from the coronavirus
so
i dispute that that is justification for
what was done
also the directives that come from the
government
our recommendation
and they are directives
and you are asked as counselors to
interpret those directives
and to
do what is appropriate in your area
and
we do not think that it was appropriate
to lock down the entire area on such low
figures
could we have a response from cancer
connie
i thank the question for for the
supplementary um i'm not so light about
five deaths as the question appears to
be we've provided a response to it i
believe the council has done all it
could and should have done to protect
the people of teambridge to support our
communities our residents our businesses
i make no apology for the work the
council has done i thank the staff and i
thank all councillors for their support
through the pandemic it was the right
thing to do and i'm not ashamed of it
thank you chairman
thank you leader cancer connect can i
remind questioners that we have a 15
minute time spell for these questions
although i will be flexible i would like
to get keep any supplementaries
relatively short and to the point if you
can your question too
we have a response from the leader which
is as above have you ever supplementary
to that
question two was from july 2020 time
when the corona virus act allowed the
councillors to take full responsibility
over the health outbreak decision-making
at times of adapting the coronavirus act
as necessary as an administrative tool
to perform a councillor's duty have you
been aware of the official official
government covert 19 status dated march
2020 which clearly states covid 19 was
no longer considered a high consequence
infectious disease in the uk
this was four days before we were put
into lockdown
are you aware
that
the kovid 19 status in march 2020
was no longer considered a highly
consequence a high consequence
infectious disease
yeah can i remind you that was your
original question a response has been
given have you a supplementary to that
no that was not given that is question
two
i believe i've adequately responded a
question to uh there are very many
people who've been affected by kovid
both in district and across the country
i think the council's done absolutely
the right thing it followed public
health advice excuse me you have not
answered the question were you aware of
the advice of the children
that covered 19
was categorized
as
no longer being considered as a high
consequence infectious disease you have
not answered the question i've provided
the response chairman i have nothing
further to address the council has done
the right thing chairman can we move on
to question three please
that is not an adequate answer question
three please explain how proposed
council constitutional changes of
excluding and limiting the residents
from questioning the council performance
could be justified under this
councillor's seven principle code of
conduct and under contractual law and by
that i refer to the nolan principles
we have a response from the leader
now have you a supplementary to that
i want to know how you feel you have
upheld the nolan principles
in the way that you have responded
cancer and how that has affected your
constituents it's a very simple question
okay the leader at cancer connect
thank you chairman the fact that the
questioner is here today as they're
putting a written written question has
got a written responses asking
supplementary disease for the fact that
we are following the nolan principles
many of us would have had correspondence
from our residents and responded to that
i think the council has done all it can
and should have done i think we do
follow the nolan principles chairman
thank you
can we just talk about accountability
then excuse me that
you have not upheld your nolan
principles excuse me we're moving on
kendrick mcgregor well please remember
that we vote you in and that you are
public servants and by not answering
questions you are failing to do your
public duty to stop at this time thank
you fit for office
do you have a comment counselor mcgregor
thank you chair it was just to add that
we are accountable to the the residents
of the the district and every
four or five years we we stand
accountable at the election box and
residents have a chance to judge us by
our actions during the period of the
administration uh each time there's a
change of administration in the council
and i think it's fair to say that
accountability can be determined at that
point and i think thank you very much
for your patience on on that chair
thank you councilman mcgregor we move on
to questioner two
and that is amanda rowe
now she's given a question and she has
had a response a written response from
the leader
does she have
a supplementary
you're just telling me that i've had
my questions answered already
i haven't had them answered
there is a written response have you not
got a copy of the written response no
who who would have given that to me i
haven't had anything
just bear with me i sent them in i
haven't had a written response i'm not
an answer
yeah
but i'm here to ask questions and you're
here to answer them aren't you a
response has been given a written
response it's there given to you now i
believe if you've not had it previously
given to me
right if you'd like to ask the question
and the response is there in writing now
and then if you have a supplementary
could you please ask it
so you've already answered my questions
about half an hour ago and i didn't know
the the written response has been given
and i presume you'd had a copy but if
that's not the case so is this how you
do business then this is always how we
give a written response to a question
you'd submitted so we had to ask these
questions two days before your meetings
and you answer them on the morning of
the meeting what half an hour before
this meeting you've answered my
questions
not very fair would you say
yeah
i'll pass you to the leader
cancer connect
thank you chairman uh for very many
years uh residents have been able to ask
questions of the council but it's
questions to the council at a council
meeting so the questions are submitted
in advance and we provide the written
response at the meeting
and that would have been made available
it should be made available to residents
when they arrived so the written
question is set out for all cancers and
members of the public
there's a written response from me and
of course the member of public is
entitled to ask a supplementary question
and and do you render these questions
the answers to these questions at the
last minute
they're made available at 10 a.m at the
start of the meeting yes
so that is the answer to that that is
the response and if you can formulate a
supplementary at this time then that's
fine so so if the question has a
supplementary i'm happy to deal with it
chairman because there are a number of
questions here and i'm keen to get
as many of the residents able to answer
questions as possible so it works
fine for you if amanda doesn't have a
supplementary we can move to the next
question we'll move on to the next
question please all right have you ever
seen basically my question was
what data and just a file of evidence
for shutting all the businesses down
i don't know if you're aware of the
people that committed suicide had
depression
um
wasn't it surely their their choice it's
people's choice to go into shops isn't
it they can go into all the big
essential supposedly shops
so why enforce smaller businesses to
shut down when people surely have the
freedom of choice to go in anyway
so chairman we wouldn't yes we would
have worked within national guidelines
uh i don't think the council shut
anything down other than operating
within the national framework as part of
the pandemic well i know how i know
shops were shut down it was supposedly
illegal which isn't unlawful and the
coroner act is only an act isn't it yeah
where's many guidelines so it's your
decision to make people go bankrupt
we're not into a link prolonged
discussion on this you have a sad
supplementary and the leaders answer it
could i ask move on to the next
questioner please so it's it's almost
like a recorded answer you give people
it's not a
from the heart answer or even from your
questions are very similar and the
leader has responded to those questions
can i move on please to the next
questionnaire
and that is julie and moran please
really think that you need to you need
to read your deep data
supplementary questions please we've had
as i said the written answer is there so
we need a supplementary to the written
answer all i can say is it is not
acceptable
is that that's your comment that's no
question then basically well it is
i mean it seems like
um nobody
has had their questions answered so far
can i
can i call my question outside everybody
knows about it yes
the central government introduced the
corolla virus as a temporary and limited
flexible interpretation of existing
constitutional regulations this
temporary guidance on how to deal with a
health emergency mainly executive
councillors to make a decision as to
whether a lockdown is necessary and
therefore the only option to keep
residents safe during the outbreak this
decision could only be supplemented by
local and national health and
data obtained by careful assessment with
the residents my question was
why was the decision to lock down
davidson devon not discuss with the
public before as advised by the
transparency act 2015 and justified with
required evidence as advised under the
coronavirus act
and as the last
speaker said
we've only just had this response
and i haven't i don't agree with it and
the response from the leader was under
direction yeah we've all got a copy of
the response do you have any
supplementary to that i just don't agree
with it i i just think this is all wrong
can i pass it on you are not answering
the questions
i'll pass over to the leader for a
response
i i understand uh the question or may
not like the response but the response
sets out the facts of the matter and
that is a response uh the council has
done all that it could and should have
done in fact
our staff have worked very hard to get
out the
business grants to support businesses
through the pandemic
and many businesses have actually been
supported and sustained by the work of
the council i appreciate the question as
a particular view it is not one i agree
with
well i mean you work for us
or we work well whatever i i just don't
agree with it if if there's no further
questions can we move on
all of us were elected by residents as
councilor mcgregor said he led by
residents to serve and represent
them you'll have to be re-elected i'm
i'm elected by the people of kentucky
and the questioner wants to come and
stand in 2023 in in may of that year in
the election is more than welcome to uh
and she can put her case to the
electorate if that's the issue but at
think
what needs to be done now at the moment
at the moment i am very proud of team
bush district council its councillors
its members of staff and all the work
that we've done to support businesses
and our communities throughout the
pandemic
we have to move on and said we've only
15 minutes right as i will be flexible
but we the time is drawing on so we have
corey colley
she has one question um i hope she's had
time to read the response and can she
give a supplementary please i have read
your response unfortunately i seem to
have the generic reply that everybody
else seems to have had to their
questions which is completely
unsatisfactory
team bridge council are independent from
the county council and you just
continuously pass the buck and expect me
to now put my questions to the county
council i wanted a response from you
personally
and i don't now expect to have to go to
county council you are individual people
i am guessing that most of you are
parents or grandparents and you should
be caring about the lives of children
you should be looking deeper into the
research of whether these vaccines for
children should be going ahead
you are literally about to commit
genocide to the young population by
i'm going to ask the speaker to withdraw
that disgusting remark no one in this no
one in his chamber is responsible for
genocide that was an outrageous insult
to everyone could you withdraw that
professionals have advised against this
and it's been ignored by the government
so chairman the response the response is
this actually team registration council
is not an education authority and we're
not responsible for vaccinating
12 to 15 year olds it is a decision that
sits with government and it is an action
that falls to the nhs and public health
we've tried to assist the questioners in
getting the right authorities to answer
the question
many of us in this room will be parents
and we'll take an individual view about
whether we wish our 12 to 15 year olds
to be vaccinated or not that is not
though a question for team bush district
council i repeat again i request the
questioner to withdraw the disgusting
remark made regarding genocide
as a council are you prepared to
withdraw that question
you make decisions within are you
withdrawal i think the education board
it's not just the government
you can personally act on your own
thoughts and advice
and you're not doing that i think we'll
have to withdraw at this time so can you
please we'll move on to the next
questionnaire please
kim angel
and can i stress please you know that we
ask supplementary questions only and
await the response from the leader and
when he gives a response can we leave it
at that please
um no we can't
i've waited a long time to be able to
have my say
my thoughts i represent quite a few
people in the newton abbott district
and they have asked and been coming to
me for a very long time i've got tons
and tons of emails
and i've been asked what's going on
so no i won't skip it's been
a long process
waiting
to be heard
and as you know
people will only put up
being ignored for so long
so i'm here
as a peacekeeper to get and be
acknowledged
the information that i keep being asked
so i'm going to
politely
ask my questions
and i expect
a verbal response
because this is being recorded publicly
is it not
there is no point
me asking the questions
and because i have a piece of paper
that i was given half an hour ago in
response to my questions
the public will not hear your response
to the questions that i put forward so
with your patience your kindness your
generosity
i will ask the questions
and could you please
respond so that the public can hear the
response
my first question
during the lockdown months of 2020 2021
a number of the local services that
should be provided
by the council as contracted we the
residents haven't been provided and
others strictly limited
the residents however
been
paid have been paying for their full
council tax as stated in an original
contract do you consider
a refund
as part of your kovid recovery
plan
can i ask the leader to come in there
certainly chairman uh i'd like to thank
my colleagues on the overview scrutiny
committees for their excellent work
regarding the kobe recovery plan that
sets out in great detail what it is the
council is doing to support the economy
and businesses and residents of team
bridge
there is no refund on the council tax
thank you chairman
your next question please
my next question
is
what data
information
do you use to justify
advertising covered hot spots
in newton abbot and the team bridge area
and i would like to just point out
one of the seven principles that guide
you as an elected public body
number two
integrity holders of public office must
avoid placing themselves under any
obligation to people or organizations
that might try inappropriately to
influence them in their work they should
not act or take decisions
in order to gain financial or other
material benefits
for themselves their family or their
friends they must declare and resolve
any interests
and relationships
council look on it
we don't advertise government hotspots
that's your answer we do not advertise
covered hotspots we have seen the van
with
it's a council van
with
the flash on the side with the
lights on it that gets switched on
driving
around saying that we
have a high incidence
of
covid
i've seen this
we've also got pictures of it right the
leader
chairman as i say the council doesn't
advertise covered hot spots it's a
council lorry
chairman
excuse me the leader is answering are we
to be interrupted um
the council does not advertise kevin hot
spots chairman if the questioner has
something different then please email me
the picture and i'll make further
inquiries quite happily however there
has been in the past a rise in covid
within the district as many people will
know and been following the reports from
public health england and governor
county council's public health on that
so it would be a matter of fact
thank you chairman
your final question and can you please
just if there's any supplementary point
you wish to make but no i'm going to ask
the third one because this has been
publicly recorded and people will want
to know my question and they will want
to hear your answer because they cannot
unfortunately see
the answer that you gave me half an hour
ago
three who can i just make a point to you
all the answers that have been given to
you in in writing are on the company on
the cambridge website so all members of
public can see this attached to the
agenda so the everyone will be able to
see them
i'm asking for your patience
i'm asking for your courtesy
to allow me to ask my question
and
your could you please ask it then please
number three
who
what
company provides you with
above mentioned data
information
the data information
of
the rising
covid
in newton abbott and team bridge area
who advises you
on that data that we have numbers rising
right so that's your final question can
i pass to the leader please so we will
receive information on damon county
council public health public health
england chairman thank you there we are
that's the answers can i ask and we now
move on that's it no i didn't get my you
gave everybody else a chance to do the
one off the cuff one and i'd like to do
that in
reply to your last question
you obviously know who steve brown is
he's a devon's director of public health
and he said
and i quote
coronavirus is still with us and while
case rates in devon have fallen in
recent weeks they are likely to rise
unquote
this was posted on the 14th
of september
seven days ago
2021
posted in community
devon county council homepage devon
county council so how can
numbers have risen
in such a short time
as to be out there promoting and
advertising for people to get vaccinated
by
an untested
no long-term adverse effects
reports
why are you still promoting
the vaccine
could ask cancer heat and you have a
point
it's dangerous to say what's just been
said
this vaccine has been tested and it has
had data published about it
and we have to rely on experts my father
used to say he wouldn't drink the beer
from a landlord who wouldn't drink his
own beer or my medical friends
and all the specialists and scientists
that i know couldn't wait to vaccinate
themselves and now their children and i
think we should put an end to this
conversation because it's not it's it is
an emergency can i ask you please
to cease now i i want the leader to make
a final comment on those questions and
that is the end of your questions
side effects
can we turn the microphone off please
gentlemen
um
[Applause]
i i'm i'm well aware that the questions
are seeking to use the fact that we're
broadcasting a meeting to peddle their
particular views about coronavirus i
have no truck with it i'm grateful to
councillor eden for that intervention
regarding uh the work that's been done
it's an individual matter whether people
choose to be vaccinated or not i think
those that have done the right thing i
respect the decision for those who have
chosen not to that's a matter for them
but i'm equally satisfied that there is
a pandemic there is a coveted
coronavirus and
we have taken the right actions to
support our residents and our
communities and our businesses
can we can i please ask you to sit down
please and and and in the in that
chairman
please can you be quiet please thank you
so so thank you chairman i understand
the questions point of view i disagree
with it entirely thank you very much
thank you chairman thank you leader
right we have now got two questions
which have had written responses from
sarah n and lisa goody uh neither of
these are here today i do not believe so
we will move on
to
mia stat stasted if i pronounce that i
apologize if i haven't she has three
questions or three supplementary
questions please
is she here
she's had to leave early fine okay thank
you that brings to the end
to the end of questions from members of
the public thank you very much
and i was a bit lenient with going on a
little bit longer there because i did
try to help you put your questions
but i'm afraid we went on quite a bit
longer than we normally do
yes counselor jeffrey is it
just to say i've lost my wi-fi somewhere
i lost the wi-fi
sorry have you have your question kenja
jeffrey
oh okay sorry about that
right
now then we're going to move on to
item six which is canceller questions
and
first of all
we have two questions and the first of
those from councillor eden
um hello um yes so um
i've read the answer um from councillor
dewhurst and my question was about how
confident is councillor dewhurst about
the district's recycling not being
exported um to third country locations
and uh he sent me to a website link
i actually asked him how confident he
was so can he actually answer the
question for me please
cancer dewhirst
thank you very much yes i am very
confident i sent you to the website
because as as i know you know councillor
eden i'm very keen that all our members
are aware of what is on our website and
the the useful information that's there
and on that particular link it tells you
where or all our materials are going
and as i say i'm very confident that
they're going to those places
thank you
all right counseling you have another
question yes supplementary so um yes so
my second question was about um what
checks and confirmations can be provided
that show beyond reasonable doubt that
recycling collected across team bridge
from responsible householders um is
actually 100 processed and 100 percent
recycled
i do have a response from councillor
dewhurst um and it's not very
quantitative he talks about the vast
majority and i'm wondering what data led
him to say vast majority and then he
says we have a statutory duty to
quantify i'm quite right and quantify
means measuring it means actual hard
data it doesn't mean guessing um so i'm
hoping he can actually do what he said
he's going to do and actually quantify
and define what majority means and then
he says again how confident he is he
says he's very confident that we're
taking necessary steps so i'd like to
know what he means by vast majority
cancer duration
i thank councillor eden for her question
and
um
the the response
was that the vast majority does in fact
remain in the uk
i can't quantify it here but i will get
a written response
as to the percentage uh that does remain
in the uk there is a small quantity of
cardboard
that goes to germany
at the moment and we have never said
that all our recycling
go remains in in the uk i am confident
that it this is what happens because
almost the very first question i asked
when i became executive member
for recycling household waste and
environmental health is what happens to
our waste and can i
be assured
that none ends up in places like asia
and
the far east
where it's not recycled
in good conditions and i was shown how
the system works
with
checks by devon county council
and and also the environment agency so i
am confident and confident in our
offices
who do an amazing job and have done an
amazing job throughout this pandemic
when
quantities of
recycling and waste
residual waste have increased
dramatically
and as such we're sort of operating in
christmas conditions at the moment
so that's why i can't tell you
what the vast majority
specifically is in tonnages but i'll get
you them that
in due course councillor eden thank you
thank you country
cancer eden yes thank you um i'm sorry
but i i do think that we should be
better prepared and you have had some
time for that question and to say
do you use words like vast majority and
very confident you know does vast
majority mean 70 percent 60 80 90
i want the data and the public deserve
figures not
airy fairy phrases i think cancer jew
has just given is his answer to that so
uh he's going to provide further
information at a later date so thank you
uh you have a further question
not for cancer juice but you have
further question for someone else yes oh
okay so do we go to the next ones then
yes
all i wanted to say i i just wanted to
ask um
councillor wrigley to make sure he
doesn't stop providing such excellent
information he gave me proper data
proper answers i think some of his
colleagues could take a few lessons from
him
okay
do you have a response to that counselor
thank you very much this is an important
issue and we are very much aware of the
uh horrific state that you can get into
the horrific state of being homeless and
it is horrible and we are doing
everything that we possibly can to
prevent that for as many people as we
can and we are continuing our efforts as
we go through and we're very much
keeping an eye on it with the ridiculous
idea of removing the 20 pound a week
uplifting universal credit which will be
disaster for so many families in the
area
combined with the increase in heating
cap heating costs and the level
inflation we have at the moment so we
are
very closely monitoring the impending
storm that we anticipate
cancellation is to have another question
or is it linked with that question yes
no but i just i did have a question
related to the next one which was about
um which is for uh about airbnb should i
go onto that one
i'm getting confused sorry am i i don't
have any more questions from martin
your counselor wrigley
just bear with me
okay and we'll we'll move on um i think
cancer jefferies had a question
oh
yes yes that's your question council
eden and cancer jefferies is mentioned
no supplementary to that
it's all clear
not from the leader that's fine
i think we now move on to a question
from councillor malone
at the back
i don't mind which one of you
councilman do you have a supplementary
to the response you've been given
um
yeah
i i i i thank the uh
the councillor for his response it's uh
sadly was more flannel than than we had
in the 1970s uh it was a long time ago
now so i i'll remind members of
the the planning meeting of january 21st
2020 was rather a contentious one and
after a while a planning advisory
service group was charged with
investigating irregularities within it
returned a verdict of nothing to see
though almost all our concerns were
unaddressed chief among these was our
frustration that in a massive decision
that turned on the chairman's casting
vote can i just interrupt council ramon
can i ask you not to handle the
microphone if that's possible well
otherwise i'm not speaking into it
properly am i i just just get the
the gentleman to hold the boom in front
of you if that's possible yeah it's
being stuck into my nose which is
uncomfortable so i'll just hold it like
this if that's right with you um
the two speaking slots against
development were allocated not to
concerned locals or their advocates but
the persons unknown who have since
become known as the ghost objectors
and who have always been kept secret
from urs and the public my supplementary
question
hinges on this
we know who the objectors were we always
knew but it took 18 months to gather the
evidence and the documents the first
objector
slot was given to a 23 year old male
described by a former employer as having
learning difficulties who is on record
as saying that he was encouraged to
write a letter of objection by a friend
of his mother a person who worked for
tdc in the planning department the
letter was received before the
application was even validated and was
selected by tdc from the 100 or so
received he was a farm laborer whose
previous employer was one anthony rowe
the farmer and chief landowner of the
na3 development the letter he wrote was
a poetic entreaty he did not object on
planning grounds it was not an objection
that was admissible under tdc guidelines
he does not live in tin bridge but on a
still under construction development in
payton in a family house that was
entirely owned by london homes prior to
the planning meeting he was telephoned
by a council officer in fort house who
solicited him to be a speaking objector
along with his brother a second objector
even though his brother had made no
objection written no letter and had no
interest in the issue thus were these
spots so precious to the other side of
the argument filled by tdc it appears
neither of them contrary to what we were
told suffered a bereavement on the
morning of the january 21st that
prevented them coming they simply didn't
come we have asked many times for full
disclosure on the ghost objectives and
have been advised that the withholding
of this information under gdpr is a
misrepresentation of what gdpr is for
we asked the executive member for
planning to be honest with us several
times under part two conditions we got
silence we have exhausted every official
polite courteous and reasonable avenue
and got nothing but obstruction and
contempt so now this is happening due to
this straw manning abbott's curseville
parish council and the warbler of
residents association were unable to
bring the expert from oxford to put
forward a scholarly environmental case
for the planning committee to hear the
speaking slots were knowingly
misallocated by tdc officers breaching
their own rules in a deliberate attempt
to disadvantage the case against
adoption of the proposal the planning
committee was lied to
the leadership of this council has
committed at the very least conspiracy
to defraud the can i ask you
by the willful and deliberate prejudices
please
you are in contempt of the law and in
contempt of the people so can the
chairman
can you sit down please
[Music]
chairman chairman if if council malone
would like to provide the evidence that
seemingly me and my colleagues have
never seen or heard then perhaps that
would help or we can adjourn the meeting
chairman
please we're going to start live
streaming again in just a second
right
thank you councillors
um i am going to now pass over to the
company's
solicitor paul woodhead for a statement
thank you chair
members and all president would have
just
witnessed the events of a few minutes
ago and heard the allegations made
and i'm sure would appreciate that no
one here is in a position to comment
further in respect of what was said at
this time
and indeed it perhaps would be
inappropriate to do so in any event
the council
who's raised those issues is invited to
meet with me
and or to provide me with
the information that he has alluded to
and made reference to
whereupon it will be properly considered
and investigated as appropriate thank
you chair
thank you very much paul
and i would just say that if we can
continue this meeting now
with a sense of decorum and i don't want
any more further outbursts from anyone
um otherwise we will have to suspend the
meeting again so if we can continue in a
sensible manner please and i'm going to
pass over now to the next
questionnaire which will be councillor
dawes who's got three questions and i
could ask him to give a supplementary to
each question
thank you yes uh i do have a
supplementary to my first question which
was uh did tdc uh team bridge district
council reply to their letter uh from
client earth of the second of september
2019 which outline the council's legal
uh obligations of in terms of climate
change
i've been given a response uh which uh
suggests that uh though they didn't
reply the council is implementing
the uh the obligations within its local
plan um the the issue with that is that
it is more rhetoric and less uh
less action and uh it's the shame that
the high water mark that it appears to
aspire to
stays in a realm of rhetoric
the scrapping of the woolworth dpd which
should have been put in place
for the protections of the highly
sensitive na3
is a very
poor example of that planning having
wasted a hundred thousand pounds worth
of taxpayer funds i know the um
leader was very upset about the
accusation of genocide well the council
is certainly guilty of environmental
genocide and i think that will remain a
matter of fact
um
and uh we would like the executive to uh
be judged uh on their actions in the
fullness of time
my second question can i just take one
at a time if that's possible yes sure
okay could i have a an answer from the
portfolio holder counselor hook
thank you chair and um thank you for the
question as stated in the answer um the
letter was constructed but not sent due
to purder and we were approaching a
general election at that point um surely
it's important here that we took on
board the content of their letter which
of course had in fact always been our
intent
um the local plan working group of which
richard is a member councillor doors met
several times to construct carbon
reduction policies
at which councillor doors had the
opportunity with others to
check whether a reply to client earth
letter had been sent post-election
planners have taken on board a variety
of comments from the public act the
university of exeter client earth and
others to come up with a robust and
comprehensive set of carbon neutral
policies that will be demanding of
future planning applicants
there's really no need for this to be
confrontational i've never wanted to be
our action on climate to be
confrontational i have a long-standing
constructive dialogue with a range of
climate activists and environmental
pressure groups local and national i'm
confident that the council is aware of
its legal obligations with regards to
climate change
and although i don't believe client
earth have made contact with the council
again since 2019 i'm very happy to
re-establish contact contact and
hopefully have a constructive dialogue
with them to help better understand how
the council can support our district
reaching its carbon neutral target
we've always said we can't do this alone
as a council and we will all need to
work together and i'm very happy to do
so
thank you councillor hook uh councillor
doors have you supplementary to your
second question yes so my second
question was uh
asking the uh team bridge district
council to make uh public its response
to the letter from buxton's
environmental that again analyzed the
legal obligation the council still holds
uh in respect of any environmental and
climate change obligations in
in relation to na3 sites uh the
solicitor's bookstore environmental
wrote tdc to ask if they're
aware that the obligations remained
uh the public can be forgiven to think
that full planning permission has been
granted for an e3 the overwhelming
issues remain
uh these are large environmental and all
the climate change concerns and they
have to be addressed they should
sensibly have been addressed in the
master plan for an a3 the dpd that this
executive cancelled
if the council is at all committed to
environmental protections it should
reinstate a master plan for an e3 with
oversight from members and transparency
to the residents rather than deal
piecemeal with the numerous applications
so will the portfolio hold the commit to
replying to the letter and reinstating
the master plan for the whole site
rather than giving developers the upper
hand dealing with each and every
application piecemeal
thank you councillor taylor
thank you for the question and uh no we
won't be responding uh to the letter
thank you
and a supplementary to your third
question cancer at all
yes my third question was uh
whether the conflict of interest were
outlined in relation to the planning
advisory service investigation
into the langford bridge uh in
investigation
the answer to the question is that
the chair of the planning committee did
declare that he'd worked for the
planning advisory service at the meeting
where the council committed to
invite the
planning advisory service in so that's
one declaration
of many meetings in the single call that
we had with the planning advisory
service it became quickly apparent that
the officer in charge of the
investigation richard crawley had a
professional working relationship with
the chair of planning
under uh investigation it would have
been wholly proper
uh due process that that was declared
throughout the
uh investigation
members have been consistently
hoodwinked and treated with contempt
members have voted in voted in good
faith by the representatives to make
decisions and offer scrutiny the
planning advisory service failed to
address the seven huge concerns against
the planning decision for langford
bridge
and in doing so may well have conspired
to defraud the residents of team bridge
and their failures to follow due process
in investigating this meeting
the leadership of this council has
committed at the very least conspiracy
to defraud the residents of team bridge
by willfully and deliberately
prejudicing and opening an open and fair
planning meeting
the ghost object as alluded to by
councillor malone
uh were known were questioned on the
four o'clock on the 21st of january 2020
and since that date
it certainly is not
bearing in mind the comments that
solicitor has just made can i have you
got a question a direct question about
can the chair of planning committee
offer an explanation as to why he didn't
declare his professional working
relationship with the lead investigating
officer at any junction throughout the
council meetings of the investigation
into langford bridge
council taylor
it's a question uh thank you chair is a
question for members
regarding declaring an interest and
that's not something that i can comment
on afraid
thank you
right
now we questions have come from the
portfolio holder and that that is where
we end this matter we'll go on to the
next question which is from councillor
percer
over to the left please
thank you chairman um just perhaps
highlights the breadth of things that
district councils have to deal with
i and my constituents would like to
thank the leader for the response and
look forward to the amendments being
made by the end of october i have no
further supplementary question thank you
chair
thank you council apparature
now we have some questions from
councillor patch
wherever he is yep i've got the
microphone i'm sorry couldn't see you
that's okay um supplementaries please
okay thank you yeah my first question
asked whether the document purporting to
be the constitution of this council had
been properly scrutinized to assess
record and present to members all of the
material changes in the document
compared to the previous version of the
constitution to be properly adopted
i did not receive an answer to that
unfortunately
although i believe it's quite apparent
that it has not been so scrutinized my
supplementary question
who gave explicit authorization late
last year for the removal from the
council website of its adopted
constitution and its replacement with an
unadopted document and who was consulted
on this and or had knowledge at the time
that it was being done
can i pass the leader against reconnect
um
i'll just wait for you
just wait for the
engine
um thank you chairman i'm i'm grateful
to councillor patch for
um the questions on the constitution
i don't agree with his premise about how
this started out so council
authorized the solicitor
to amend and update the constitution
which was done
um
to my satisfaction
we have a current and valid constitution
the question that council patch puts
more generally is
how did we come about with that and
that's why the council when it
recognized actually but it's been
operating for very many years but didn't
have a formal procedure for actually
reporting these things
to members set up the procedures
committee and that's met and we're going
to discuss that
as an item on today's council agenda so
that that
speaks to the fact that points have been
raised members have taken that into
account changed the way the council is
working and the constitution is being
looked at but we need a constitution
that the council can work by and i think
council is satisfied or should be
satisfied that it gave an instruction to
the council solicitor to update and
amend the constitution which was done
and that's the one we're working from
until such time as the council
looks again the council's look again to
consider what further amendments or
changes it might like or whether it was
to revert to uh wording that was used in
the earlier edition of the constitution
chairman thank you
thank you leader uh you have second
question councillor patch in a
supplementary please
thank you obviously i don't want to
preempt too much the debate that will
take place under this item but just to
come back on something that the leader
mentioned
the process for putting this new
document in place
councillors were given assurance at the
time that authority was given delegated
authority to update the constitution
there
there would not be significant material
changes as my original motion has set
out in some detail there are significant
material changes to the detriment of the
rights of members of the public to
scrutinize the council and to the
detriment of members of this council to
scrutinize the council um
these changes have not been scrutinized
i'm just so moving on to question two
then um
just just bear
can we just have a supplementary please
i'm coming to that now question two the
supplementary concerns the language used
in the recommendations to reaffirming um
the document and my supplementary
question is is it lawful or legally
sufficient to reaffirm an unadopted
document as the constitution of this
council for it actually to become the
constitution of this council i would
recommend an answer to this be found
before we reach item eight on today's
agenda
can't you connect so again chairman i
understand what councilor patch is
seeking to achieve in the sense of do we
have a lawful constitution i don't agree
with his understanding and
interpretations of it and that the
council authorizes solicitor to
modernize a main update which was done
and we have that
uh council patch says there have been
substantial changes which go beyond
minor amendments that's his view
and we've set up a procedure to look at
that so we've got procedure screening
that comes up in the next part of it
i'm satisfied and other members may well
be satisfied that we are operating from
a valid constitution and the procedures
committee chose the word reaffirm as in
to say yes the november 2020 edition the
modernized updated edition is the one
that we are working from and i i think
we are getting torn over whether we use
reaffirm confirm reconfirm when that's
actually not necessary what we're trying
to do is understand the points that
council patches be making
set up a system to deal with it and it's
a piece of forward it's a piece of work
that is ongoing thank you chairman
thank you leader
and and the final supplementary please
councillor patch thank you uh well just
to say that document has never been
affirmed adopted at all before so i
don't see how it can be reaffirmed or
re-adopted in any case question three i
asked about um the recommendations for
changes to the planning committee
and or operation planning procedures
and
whether this had come from a proper
review of any sort so my supplementary
question
has the council within the last 18
months received any formal complaints
about planning procedures at the council
or any complaints against officers of
this council with regard to planning
procedures and determination of planning
applications at this council and if so
have any such complaints been formally
investigated
the leader
thank you um
i'm not able to answer that now but i'm
happy to provide a written response by
the members newsletter
what i would say of course is that the
recommendations which appear in the
council's agenda day come from a piece
of work arising from a standards
committee hearing
and then consideration made up
procedures which are presented to
members today for their consideration to
vote for or against as they wish
but that is being the journey of the
procedures that are all the
recommendations before council today
thank you
chairman thank you leader
right we now move on to the next
question and a supplementary please
from councillor malone
yeah this i presume this is my question
about the the new revised working times
yes yeah thank you uh yeah i i was i i
thank you for your answer i frankly it's
just it's just not good enough
i mean apart from everything else that's
going on here you're laying the council
wide open for civil actions under basic
human rights legislation because you're
removing the democratic representation
of every citizen who's elected
representative cares for a family or a
relative or who works for a living i i i
appreciate that you've pointed me
towards the public purse on this uh that
you know there's there's money available
to get carers in i have a child with
special needs i can't just leave him uh
with with anyone who happens to be
available just so that i can serve my
constituents uh i i think this this new
working times is written on the
assumption that all counsellors are old
retired and blessed with limitless time
and i i tell you what really winds me up
and what forms my supplementary okay
if any of my group misses a single
meeting the uh the deputy leader goes
them on facebook like a 12 year old and
tells the abbot's kurzweil page how
awful we are so if we cannot go to
meetings because maybe like me we have
three children or people with special
needs to look after is he going to sit
in his empty nest with all the time in
the world and carry on crowing that
we're not representing our electorate
while his own executive has deliberately
made that impossible for us
thank you councilman alone
i will answer this
i i can assure you councilman that this
this decision was taken in conjunction
with the views of all the chairs of the
committees there was never going to be
one perfect answer
there was never a aimed at excluding any
individual counsellor
the decarbonization of fort house was
and is a priority
to carry on with the existing timetable
of meetings was going to cause
interruption and delay
to the work which had to be carried out
and also difficulties for those
attending meetings
as as the work is designed to commence
in december of this year and hopefully
be completed by march although that can
be not guaranteed we are talking a very
limited time period there was never
going to be a precise answer to this
situation it's just something we had to
do to progress the work as soon as we
possibly could so
i'm sorry that is the answer and we have
never intended to that doesn't actually
answer the question which was uh is
councillor jew hurst going to stop uh
goading as if we have to look after our
kids rather than turn up at a meeting i
i don't think that's a relevant question
can i think it's a very relevant
question uh i'll rephrase it is it going
to grow up
uh certainly not when that's going to be
answered i hope we can continue this in
a civil manner please
thank you that's that's the answer to
that question
no we uh council eden
thank you thank you yes um just a small
comment that four o'clock is really a
dreadful time to pick because if you've
got children to pick up from school
you've got to get there you've got to
get back you've got tea and and i do
wish there'd been maybe i missed an
email but i do wish there'd been more of
a consultation because you know for a
lot of us actually a start at six would
be an awful lot better four is the worst
possible time you know you're doing
you're doing your kids tea you're
picking them up you know it's hopeless
it's going to be very difficult for me
and any other working parent i imagine
to meet four o'clock
uh i i repeat a lot what i said to
council malone there was never going to
be a precise answer
if there is a desire from councillors to
move it to a later time at say 6 p.m
then that is certainly something that
can be considered uh it's not to um but
it didn't make it difficult for
councillors this this is not an exact
science so we're just trying to get the
work completed and you know
it's so difficult we're never going to
please everyone so uh if there's a
desire um to move to six o'clock and
that's something we could possibly do
but that's something that would have to
be decided after this meeting obviously
okay
thank you we've got another question oh
we've got a hand up there somewhere um
i can't see who it is from here but alex
thank you councillor parker khan thank
you chair um i i agree with the last two
speakers and i just wanted to ask
whether consideration for councillors
with caring responsibilities have been
consulted on more broadly
and whether we could have that broader
consult consultation where we ask
councillors more widely and perhaps
consider using things like old ford
house as an alternative alternative
venue for some of those smaller meetings
where we could feasibly socially
distance there and be far enough away
from the works going on so it would be
useful to have a broader consultation
please
i'll pass over to the managing director
for an answer there
thank you chairman um
uh the answer is that is of course we
will consider that we've been looking at
the uh requirements in terms of
coronavirus and what we need for
distancing and we've been taking advice
from the
environmental health officer and the
health and safety officer who who are
very well qualified to be able to give
comment on this
our primary concern is to keep officers
and counselors safe we're trying to get
the timings right so that we can use
that if we can use old ford house we
will have 10 o'clock meetings
if we need to come off site we will have
to come off site currently we are
unaware of where we'll be holding the
two council meetings so over that period
it looks like uh ons committees and
planning and
full council are going to be issues
we hope that we could try and do that in
old ford house but we're still waiting
for guidance in terms of health and
safety with that what we were trying to
give is is notice to those of you who
work who may be able to flex as well so
the actual council chamber will be
unable to be used because the amount of
drilling works that are going on are
ceilings and floors and it just would be
impractical to hold a meeting what we
had is an agreement from the contractors
that we were talking to that they would
be able to finish at before four o'clock
on the days when we're having meetings
so uh yes is your answer to that we will
try and move meetings over to old
forward house where it's safe to do so
and where we can gain access because
obviously there's issues with streaming
those meetings especially if they're
planning we've got issues with hearing
loops and there's a disability
discrimination issues of trying to get
people up and down stairs with no lift
so
unless we have every meeting off site
and this meeting is probably costing the
best part of 2 000 pounds here today
unless we hold all of the meetings off
site to be safe then there is a
significant
issue for us but we'll try and do what
we can answer parker khan to to
accommodate those meetings at old
fordhaus and those at different times
but yeah we were just trying to
safeguard people who needed to need who
work and i know there's a number of
counselors who work to be able to put
stuff in their diaries to know what was
happening thank you
thank you very much managing director i
think there was another hand up yes
cancer patch
thank you thank you briefly yes i had
intended to make the same point as
councilor parker khan i would hope that
meetings can be held in old ford house
the one meeting i think which might be
very large is the full council meeting
obviously and since we appear to be
meeting once every four months they're
not that frequent i would have hoped
that we can have an arrangement such
that the drilling would stop for the
next full council meeting and then
whether it's two months or four months
four months after that when we have
another full council meeting
just also for reference there are no
legal requirements now on social
distancing um so i don't see as why that
should be a barrier in terms of the size
of the meetings we have
thank you councillor patches sorry can i
come back there is under our health and
safety obligations to staff and
councillors so whilst there might not be
in terms of your legislation my my duty
to my staff and to you is to try and
safeguard you as best we can and that's
what we're working to it's not to do
with coronavirus social distance and
stuff it's health and safety regulations
i have that we've become under so if you
want to email email david eaton paul
nichols and john paul both thank you
thank you managing director right we're
uh
oh sorry i do apologize
cancer russell thank you for the last 12
months we've managed perfectly well
using zoom
is there no reason why we can't use zoom
in these circumstances
thank you
i i think the legislation that precludes
us from doing that unfortunately um
yeah
not really any more you can say on that
really um cancer mcgregor is that an
answer for you sorry it's not the ideal
one but um
okay mcgregor
has been asked and that should be the
end of that however i note that
councillor cook is is starting to to
wrap a coat rounder and wonder if it
might be better to move her away from
the windows where the drafts are
well we can certainly consider that as
possible
no no comments like that please cancel
them alone
yeah are you okay there counselor cook
yes she's okay i think so right we have
um
another set of questions
thanks for waiting
cancer irrelevant i think you have three
questions uh supplementaries
four
no right
i recognize how time is flowing by so
i'll be as brief as i possibly sorry i
can count
neither can the person in the first
question there are seven social rented
properties not aid as listed
delivering social
homes or homes for those people that
need them given that we've got a
thousand families in
team bridge on our waiting lists
it's extremely important our focus is on
how we provide homes for these people
and i'm delighted to see this as a start
on this process so thank you for the
detail that's given an answer to
question one
in terms of question two the size of
each property i note that the sizes here
are just above the statutory limits for
the type of accommodation that's been
provided
what is a concern for me here however is
recognizing in our capital budgets the
amount of money that's been spent on
each of these properties it works out to
be just less than three thousand pounds
per square meter of a construction cost
the specification for these houses is
obviously set at a very high standard my
concern is that the open market
currently in newton abbott
house prices
available on the market for new builds
would suggest
that the price paid for the construction
of these seven properties
is significantly higher by a thousand
pounds per square meter
than those properties that would
normally be available on the free market
if one looks at the specifications for
these houses which are extremely high
for the right reasons
if one looks at the work that mid devon
county council are doing in providing
almost identical properties
they are actually achieving a price
which is 500 pound per square meters
less
than we have paid for these properties
my point being is that we've received
money from the government we've received
the monies from s106 that is rightly
being directed in towards private
providing social or affordable homes
and that it is our duty as a council to
make sure that the maximum value is
extracted
and therefore
we could have instead of home or
providing homes for seven families
providing homes for between 12 and 14.
so there are six or five or six families
out there that could have had homes new
homes that haven't got them
can i have the assurance please from the
officers from the executive i should say
that in future they will take due regard
of the economics of providing this uh
this type of facility and make sure that
we maximize the number of homes that
we're providing for the community thank
you right
the answer to that councillor wrigley
uh thank you for the question and yes i
too i'm delighted to see the start of
the social housing building program that
we are doing
i'd like to remind council bulovan that
these are not equivalent homes that you
would find on the open market certainly
the first two at drake road have been
specially built to accommodate children
with
extra needs and they are fully
wheelchair accessible and you will see a
whole range of facilities in there
they're also built on brownfield sites
and they are built on a site that the
previous administration failed to find
anybody interested in buying or doing
anything with we have delivered new
homes on that site we've done it with
with grant money with money from the
government and we've done it effectively
we will go on and build more and we are
always looking at
a value for money and each of these
projects is costed out and estimated and
gives the appropriate return on the
project
so i'm proud to have delivered what
we've delivered so far and i'm proud
that we have a lot more in the pipeline
and we will hopefully be announcing more
in the near future
thank you councillor wrigley
answer bulletin
back up to here again please
uh thank you for the clarification about
the fact that social homes or affordable
homes do not attract uh sill or s106
payments so i i have no further
questions relative to question three but
question four
an important
step for anybody entering
or entering the homes market is access
to homes
effectively seal payments have become
attacks on
new home building and if you look at the
numbers down here had these houses
attracted still payments
people entering the market would have
had effective tax on them
of
almost 10 000 pounds per property
my question to the executive therefore
is recognizing
a
common wish for people to have homes
is it right that we have put on the cost
of a house this level of tax
and should we therefore be looking at
how we use sil
and s106
and look at how we try and recover
monies from these people when we're at a
time when house prices are escalating
and house prices become increasingly
unaffordable
these taxis represent
almost
15 percent of a current
starter home so could i ask the
executive they're prepared to look at
this the mechanism
how we charge uh sil
and how it can be adapted to make sure
that buying your first home is more
affordable for those that wish to buy
them thank you
councillor wrigley
a slightly peculiar question most of the
structure of the planning and the
construction industry is set by central
government we are
bound by what they set up and the way
this is currently put together there is
much that i would like to change but to
do that we need to change the government
and their view of planning and house
building it is government policies that
is pushing prices houses up it is
government actions that we are trying to
get around by building more social
housing and so i'm not sure that there
is anything really there for us to look
at thank you
councillor eden
thank you
councillor bulevant uses the word tax as
though it's a swear word i would
actually say we should be celebrating
what taxation brings us it brings to our
communities it pays for our schools our
health care it pays it pays for all the
things that we all want as a community
so councillor bullivant i think you
should try putting more warmth into the
word when you say tax
thank you council eden
right if there's no more questions no
more cancer questions
we will now move on to item seven on the
agenda
which is recommendation recommendations
from committees to full council and item
seven is
um
to be presented by councillor taylor i
believe
thank you chairman members item seven on
today's agenda is the recommendation
from our executive made at the meeting
of 16th of september last week which
seeks the formal agreement of full
council for matters related to the scope
resourcing timetable and governance
arrangements
towards the preparation of the
non-statutory joint strategy for east
devon exeter mid devon and tinbridge
councils
in january this year having considered
the benefits and options for continued
joint plan making following a formal
withdrawal from the greater exeter
strategic plan
full council resolved in principle to
the preparation of an unstatutory joint
strategy plan for our area
in partnership with east devon mid devon
and exeter city councils with the
support also of devon county council
such a joint strategy would continue to
provide an effective methodology towards
overarching planning policies such as
climate change mitigation and
environmental protection while at the
same time helping fulfill the national
planning policy framework requirement
under a duty of cooperation
this in-principle resolution was also
made by the relevant committees of each
of the other four partner authorities
with details relating to scope so that's
the other three partner
authorities with details relating to the
scope resourcing timetable and
governance arrangements to be agreed at
a later date
the recommendation to full council today
is focused on agreement on these final
details which have been fashioned
through a series of group discussions
with key members and officers from the
four local authorities involved in the
joint strategy and with representatives
from holmes england and the local
enterprise partnership
the same recommendations on these
details as set out in the report to the
executive last week have or very soon
will be put before east devon mid devon
and exeter city councils with the aim of
finalizing an agreement
finalizing an agreed approach to joint
strategic planning in our local planning
authority areas
moving on to these detailed matters just
briefly
the scope of the joint strategy is to be
found at 1.6 and 1.7 noting that while
the joint strategy will not set the
planning authorities of the four
authorities this being a matter for
individual district local plans
it will provide an overarching framework
that allows strategic planning and
delivery matters to be considered
collaboratively
an indicative timetable for the joint
strategy is also listed at 112
pointing to a completion and adoption
date of early 2023
a timetable now independent of
teambridge's statutory local plan review
schedule
the considerations on resourcing are
listed at 1.8 while a further commentary
on resourcing options is tabulated in
appendix a
of the five options listed option five
is the agreed recommendation which is to
engage a consultant to prepare the joint
strategy on behalf of the four
authorities supported in a limited
capacity by a group of officers
finally a diagram at appendix b
summarizes the proposed governance
structure for the joint strategy while a
commentary of the proposed governance
notes the importance of the involvement
of homes england and the local
enterprise partnership in the principles
group in helping lever in funding
brokerage and support and facilitating
development
delivery chairman members the report to
executives sets out the proposed scope
resourcing timetable and governance
arrangements for preparing a joint
strategy for east devon exeter mid devon
and team bridge the proposed
arrangements are considered to offer the
best and most appropriate option for
demonstrating and delivering a shared
approach to strategic planning matters
such as economic and housing development
carbon reduction digital connectivity
infrastructure delivery and habitat
mitigation across the four local
planning authority areas
whilst enabling each to retain control
of the scope and timetable of their own
statutory local plans
i'm therefore very pleased to put before
you the recommendation from executive
for the support of full council today
thank you
thank you councillor taylor for that
recommendation that his proposal do i
have a second cancer connect
i need to go to the vote
all those in favor
i think we need to go account
so please keep your hands at the moment
up
against
abstentions
that is carried thank you very much
right we now move on to item
eight on the agenda
this is a recommendation
from the procedures committee
and it's recommended to full council
that the council strive to uphold the
integrity of this of the constitution of
this council
that the constitution as amended by the
monitoring officer pursuant to the
resolution of full council
24th of september 19 be reaffirmed as
the council's working constitution and
the procedures committee would undertake
to consider any members queries on the
published constitution at a future
meeting
and
future changes to the constitution be
brought to the procedures committee for
onward
recommendation i know this is subject to
a bit of conversation earlier
um i believe that resolution
will take everything into account that
has been brought up and the procedures
committee has been set up to take care
of that that is see what it's there for
so i have no hesitance in recommending
that these be adopted by full council
do i have a second or please
counselor oblivion
um
any comments
here we have councillor i forget who was
first councillor cox
i think i think this is really good and
i think we do have to uh
thank councillor patch for this because
actually there was really no
mechanism to change the constitution
before the elections in 2019
then the executives sought to take off
parish councils councillors from site
meetings and they plan to do it as an
executive who read the constitution that
was unconstitutional it had to be the
full council that did it so really the
old constitution i'm afraid wasn't up to
standards it had bits and pieces at it
so i i think we now have a road map and
i i you know i think we do need to thank
cancer patch and i hope we can make the
changes that he requires i have got a
copy of the 2003 constitution in paper
form uh which we've all issued with in
the in the early days and perhaps we
need to go back to the situation where
we do give every member
a copy of the constitution i do take the
point that
the changes do seem to have gone a
little awry in
questioning on but we need to but we now
have a mechanism to change that so i
think we should work with this motion to
get the constitution we deserve thank
you
thank you council cox councillor patch
thank you um yeah i think we should put
the record straight on there being no
mechanism until this wonderful
procedures committee was set up um have
members forgot about the constitution
working group which was set up and has
sent reports to the full council before
now surely once the um once the document
had been drafted as a potential new
constitution of this council it would
have been put before the constitution
working group
this doesn't appear to have been done
the procedures committee which has been
set up has not scrutinized this document
to detail the many material changes that
are proposed in that document um
counselor conor myself disagree on the
process as to
whether or whether or not this is
actually an adopted constitution of this
council but let's let's go to the facts
of the matter
there are several documented and these
were documented in my original motion to
council last year several sorry earlier
this year several material changes in
that document to the detriment of the
rights of the public to scrutinize this
council and the rights of council
members to scrutinize this council those
go beyond the delegated authority given
to the monitoring officer
now are we as a council happy just to
nod through a document on the promise
that maybe the procedures
committee will revisit this document and
try and pull out and correct some of
those sort of loss of powers or are we
actually going to say no
maybe we we should have the procedures
committee given that the cwg didn't look
at it look at this document
provide a report to members as to the
full nature the number and nature and
extent of material changes that are
proposed in this document before we
adopt it
um i i i think
members of the public particularly at
this moment where they want to be asking
questions of the council will not take
too kindly to to councillors voting
through a document which takes away
their rights i certainly don't take
kindly to the the fact that councils
might vote through a document which
takes away rights of that i might have
to ask um
questions of this council and i know
that the the rights that have been um
inserted into this document for the uh
managing director and the monitoring
officer to
censor questions have already been used
in in the case of one question i've been
put forward so this is not a theoretical
argument it's a practical issue um
so
finally i i would ask that given it is
quite a serious issue in in terms of the
rights of residents of team bridge i
would like to request that this there be
a recorded vote on this and i would hope
that any members who are concerned about
these issues raise their hand in support
of that
yes we have that noted
okay fine
uh other comments i think counselor
malone did you have your hand up
okay fine council parker khan
thank you um i was on the procedures
committee and um
we had quite an interesting debate at
that committee i've got no problem with
certain parts of this notice of motion a
i've got no problem with we should all
be upholding the integrity of the
constitution and see future changes
should be brought to the procedures
committee for onward recommendation for
the council it's be part one i've got an
issue with and it's to do with logical
procedure
if the full council has approved the
monitoring officer to make changes then
the changes that uh the minor changes to
be made are acceptable according to the
motion that was passed by the full
council why then is this even coming to
us at council today for reaffirmation
either it's legit legislation that is
correct for her to change or it isn't
there's no need to reaffirm if she's
been given authority to do it so
what she's done stands
so why are we reaffirming it if we were
if the changes were being highlighted to
us to say these are the changes that are
being made do you agree with it i could
understand that what i don't understand
is this business of reaffirmation of
something that is already set in stone
thank you council parker khan uh
councilman regularly was the next one
uh thank you chair i have a certain
amount of sympathy for councillor
patch's uh position and indeed the
form just simply the formatting of the
way the old constitution was on the
website compared to the new one makes it
very difficult to compare
but i'd like to thank the procedures
committee for their work on this and
taking this forward and to me this is
simply a matter of saying we have a bit
of a situation here let's just draw a
line let's get the constitution
absolutely clear so no one is in any
doubt whatsoever that what is there is
what is there as councillor parker khan
said it should be there anyway and let's
bring forward i encourage councillor
patch to bring forward a full list of
all of the um
amendments that he'd like to see to the
next procedures committee as soon as
possible and go forward to me this gives
us a way of moving forward practically
and actually getting this done and any
necessary changes put in place as soon
as possible so i personally will be
supporting all of this
thank you councillor mcgregor
thank you chair um i i also sympathize
with uh councillor patch's point
um i would would suggest though that um
in terms of minor changes when you when
you make a minor change that's one minor
change but when you make a minor change
in the minor change and a minor change
in the minor change that's one plus one
plus one plus one it adds up to a much
larger number and therefore becomes a
major change
and i think that's where perhaps
councillor patch is now
raising concern is that what we've
allowed to happen is a snowball effect
so that what we start off with a small
snowball
we end up with a large ball of snow
in my in my view um i don't think i
supported this particular decision when
it came to full council the last time
and i had serious concerns around
um
um
interpretations of of things now for
instance one that's been mentioned
earlier
is
the managing director and the monitoring
officer deciding what what constitutes a
vexatious complaint or is vexas question
or a vexatious point
i don't know if fellow colleagues are
aware that this council was subject to a
decision by the ombudsman
where the monitoring officer and the
independent person
had decided
that something was vexatious in relation
to a complaint about a counsellor
and actually the local ombudsman said
you haven't defined why it's vexatious
or what it is vexatious about it
so
in actual fact
the interpretation that the ombudsman
said
was incorrect and that's where in my
view we have a concern
that things are being dealt with
appropriately and when you get lots of
little changes and it becomes a large
change that's not appropriate and that's
why i have
probably more support for the council of
patch's view on this than most of my
colleagues
thank you council mcgregor councillor
connor
um
thank you chairman um
i have great sympathy with what council
patch has raised in the sense that
council very clearly authorized the
monitoring officer to amend and update
the constitution and councillor parker
khan is right that job was done why
and and i agree with councillor parker
colon on that if it's right it's right
and if it's not
you know what are we doing about it so i
think
b1 doesn't need to be here say that
council patch has raised a significant
point and we all need to be clear that
the council says that amended
constitution is the current constitution
that's the one we're all working from
the issue around the constitutional
working group is that it is an informal
the working group doesn't have to be
diarised it can meet when it wishes and
it can be in private
there has been concern on the council
about openness and transparency a
prestigious committee meets in public
unless it needs to go into part two but
it meets in public it's on the council
agenda it's on the diary of committee
meetings and all members will be able to
see when it meets and if they want to
come or want to contribute to it they
can that is a big improvement so from
the very points that council patches
made some good work has been done to
actually improve the council's processes
the procedures committee
and what it did was look at
the work now if i step back one to the
council decision it would have been in
retrospect so much better if for example
a note they've been put into the members
newsletter saying i've modernized or
updated the uh constitution it's
available on this link let me know
within a period of i don't know five ten
days whatever it might be if you've any
comments
now for that didn't happen
uh there's no reason why it should have
happened we didn't ask for it to happen
it didn't happen the solicitor
monitoring officer did the job council
asked them to do
and we've tried to address that again
through the uh c which is future changes
to the constitution be brought to the
procedures committee that's both if the
council realizes the constitution might
be a bit out of date as they do get from
time to time but also in future if the
solicitor or monitoring officer updating
it will provide a junction at which it
could be reported to procedures and
members would have the opportunity to
engage so we avoid the circumstance that
we've got to now
and so we're navigating our way through
it and that's why i say to colleagues i
think this is a pragmatic and practical
outcome from the concerns that council
patch has raised it says look the
council does want the integrity of the
constitution
we do support the work that the council
asks the monitoring officer to do so we
are reaffirming that decision
however the procedures committee uh not
maybe but will undertake to consider
members queries on the published
constitution at future meetings so those
can be looked at and they're all future
so that's the future safeguard any
future changes would come back to the
const the procedures committee and then
back to council and that i think
responds very positively to all of the
concerns that council patches race and i
would invite members to vote for the
recommendation which has been made by
the chairman of the council and seconded
by council bulovan thank you
thank you cancer reconnect councillor
hook
thank you chair
i don't think anybody in the room is
going to disagree with
eight 8a or hc as as councillor parker
khan has
indicated would it help
to move this on and
we're in danger of making i think a
mountain out of a molehill and i don't
mean to
be disrespectful in saying that but in
in um eight
b if we simply remove the words
um
reaffirmed as
and accepted everything else that's
there would that not cover all the
comments that are being made insofar as
the any member would then be perfectly
free to bring any
issue any constitutional issue through
through a process that's outlined there
i mean i i i can see no reason against
simply removing those two words
reaffirmed as and
i would like to think we could all agree
then thank you
thank you councillor hook councillor
patch you have your hand up again
thank you
yes
i think this debate so far has just
danced around the process issues about
how this document has come forward and
whether whether or not it is actually
the um the lawful constitution of this
council i haven't heard much
talk of the actual material changes
the degradation of rights of the public
and the degradation of rights of members
of this council that are in that
document and it's true that the monarch
monetary officer did do what she was
asked to do in terms of tidying up the
constitution unfortunately she rather
went beyond that and put in material
changes which she was not authorised to
do and because of that i don't think it
can be considered the um the lawful
constitution of this council because she
went beyond the remit that was given to
her now um i i do have a great deal of
respect for councillor wrigley in all
his interventions as i've been on the
council i think it's a little unfair of
him though to give me responsibility for
scrutinizing the the new document
against the old version of the
constitution and detailing all the
changes i spent a great deal of time and
a great deal of effort looking at
selected parts of the old constitution
compared against this new document when
i submitted my note my motion back in
february um that there are documented
material changes the cwg the
constitutional working group has not
looked at this document
it's apparent well i i can tell you the
procedures committee haven't scrutinized
the material changes
it's not due down to me it is now down
to this council given the failure of the
cwg and the procedures committee to take
head-on this issue of material changes
in that document and whether it wants to
force them through because essentially
we're being told oh well that maybe
there are material changes we'll
actually know we're not talking about
them but just do it authorize this
constitution and trust us maybe we'll
look at those rights in the future and
i'm sorry that won't do
yeah i agree with councillor patch that
is the important issue here this
this new constitution does represent uh
a retreat from transparency does
represent a retreat from uh
accountability the monitoring officer
was asked to tidy up the constitution
and she took that to me to mean
changing several things that this
council did that were utterly at odds
with its own constitution at the time
and then changed them after the fact to
make it look as if no controversion took
place the monitoring officer undertook a
campaign of attrition against myself and
council adores without any formal
complaint that wasn't committed in the
constitution now hey presto it is she
said it was fine for a member to vote on
an issue where a family member would
gain even though the constitution said
it wasn't so she's tidied that up too
integrity isn't the word that really
occurs to me with regards to changes to
this constitution um
this is basically changes that are
heading away from democracy away from
transparency and that frankly
is what characterized the outgoing
monitoring officer's tenure thank you
councillor cox
the old cons the old constitution
actually contradicted itself had
different uh time scales for things what
had happened as the 2003 constitution
had been had bits added honors and
legislation changes the old standards
board of england was replaced by the
local standard it frankly was a dog's
dinner and you know and i
did the fact that the executive was uh
the previous executive was about to take
away the right of parish councils to
attend site meetings
not realizing the constant no one told
them except for me that the constitution
actually forbade that because it had to
be the change had to be made by the to
the constitution by the full council so
i can understand the reasoning and to be
honest if if we were
starting out we wouldn't have started
from where we are we have to start with
a legal and workable but perhaps
imperfect constitution from our point of
view especially over public questions
and amend that and move on from that and
not try and go back to the old
constitution i think that's the way for
we've got a process with the prestigious
committee um
i i have tried to go for it it is
actually quite difficult to go through
the old constitution and the modern one
and look at it
what we might be better doing is
actually looking at other constitutions
of other councils actually to see where
we could adopt some of their proposals
you know and i and i think the um the
ultimate sentence is you mr chairman as
the as the chairman of the council are
the guardian of that constitution um but
uh i think uh i understand what people
have said but actually if we're to move
on in any in a workable way i think
we're going to have to go with what
what's being proposed imperfect as the
situation is now we can move to change
things
councillor connie
thank you chairman
the monitoring officer did the job
council asked the monitor officer to do
um
if there is a suggestion that there are
material changes i believe that is
councillor patch's view i respect that
view i don't agree with it there have
been changes that have been amendments
there have been changes and have been
amendments
and the
recommendation to colleagues before you
from the procedures committee deals with
all of these issues
whether you accept the words be
reaffirmed or not it identifies the
constitution that the council is working
to so everyone's clear about that
and as much as councillor patch wishes
to put into some doubt about the
procedures committee's resolution to
tackle the constitution
part of our thinking was that we've
heard a lot from councillor patch about
his concerns from the constitution i say
that with respectfully to him because he
has done a lot of work on this i'm very
grateful tim for that but we've not
heard from other members who may also
have either the same concerns or
different concerns and washed to draw it
to the attention of the procedures
committee and that's why b2 is there
which is about drawing all of that in so
actually the procedures committee isn't
forever looking at the constitution but
is doing a piece of work on it and it
does take into account the concerns have
been expressed by members to a greater
or lesser degree about where we are with
it so
i would ask members to support the
recommendation that's been made by the
chairman of the council seconded by
councillor bulovan further chair i ask
that the question is now put so we go to
the vote thank you
i will allow you to come back briefly
councillor parker khan
thank you chairman um i just wanted to
ask if it was possible to request the
deferment on this item
mainly because we've had some concerns
raised here about whether the changes
made to the constitution were material
or minor and if that was if it was a
possibility for the procedures committee
to look at the tract changes to make an
assessment as to whether they were major
or minor and then come back with a
proper formal recommendation to this
council i believe that would help um
eradicate any any of the doubts that
people might have in their mind so i
don't know whether that's procedurally
possible to request a deferment on this
item
okay uh noted can very very briefly
councillor patch very briefly because
you've had your quite a bit of say on
this i do accept that chair and i thank
you for allowing me to come back for a
final time um i would i would like to
second um councillor parker khan's uh
proposal for deferment my own view is
that an amendment could be passed
to say okay if you want to authorize
this document as as or reaffirm it
however you want to sort of phrase that
then can that be done
taking due regard to the instances of
material changes that i had documented
in my original notice of motion and then
not making those material changes to the
constitution
but i i believe a deferment would be the
best option to have this looked at just
bear with me a second
thank you chairman i think we need some
clarification here i'm happy if if if mr
woodhead would would
uh if i get anything wrong but
effectively the constitution from 2020
is the constitution this council works
too that is the legally adopted
constitution that's legal in terms of
your um
instruction from the constitution
working group and from council
previously for the monitoring officer to
make changes
uh minor changes that is her discretion
you
you can't decide at this point whether
they were minor or major in your
deliberance it was it was her decision
when you delegated that responsibility
to do it to do what she thought was
minor major changes and i'm sorry
councillor patch's assertion that their
major changes is his view it's not the
legal view it's not the council's view
in terms of the organization or the
legal perspective on it that's his view
now if you wish to take that i would
suggest you take the recommendations it
is and ask prestigious committee to look
at it which is seemingly to me the
sensible thing to do and look at how you
wish to update the constitution going
forwards again but the one we legally
work to
is the one from 2020. so effectively if
you delegate it for an officer to do an
officer who is a monitoring officer has
the power to make those that they
believe to be minor changes if you
believe them to be different that's a
difference of opinion but the legal
responsibility is with the monitoring
officer to make those changes as she saw
fit at that point in time
i'm sorry councillor patcher you know
you did say it's your final point that
was so um
authority that was given by this council
to the monitoring officer and to quote
from what was in in that um that
authority for the avoidance of doubt and
as indicated above the existing rules
will not be materially changed i.e will
only cover changes to remove or address
clear errors in law or drafting to
improve clarity and understanding of the
relevant provisions as the monitoring of
circumstances considers appropriate that
is what this council agreed to
more than that has been done material
changes have been made
that's obviously your opinion councillor
patch um
well that is your documented record
which stands as a matter of law
obviously you did come back the final
time when you promised your final time
so i'm i'm going to call that to a halt
and i'll have one more counsellor who
wishes to make con no she's forgotten
that so we had a
oh we've got councillor doors they
didn't see that hand canceller doors
thank you so uh i'd agree with the
points made that uh
the original constitution the existing
constitution was probably flawed uh i'd
agree it's an iterative document that
should be updated uh council apache is
correct that the monastery officer did
overstep her authority
we should recognize that and be grown up
enough as a council to address that and
grasp that nettle uh there were two
specific points within there that were
done
primarily to cover the actions of the
monitoring officer in relation to
the
bringing standards complaints without
bringing in standards procedures without
a complaint
which changed and the monetary officer
acted outside of the constitution in
bringing complaints against myself and
councillor malone
and the conflict of interest changing
downgrading that from a family member to
a spouse uh
doesn't really sit very well and i think
everyone in this room knows why uh why
i'm talking about that and what uh what
that pertains to so uh i'd agree with
the points made by councillor patch and
urged people to vote against that
element of this motion
um thank you the managing director is
gonna clarify i just wanted one point
because it seems to be one that seems to
miss time and time again that the the
role of the monitoring officer is to
hold the standards of the organization
um
beyond beyond the
containment of items in the constitution
is their overriding
need to maintain standards if they feel
there is a a situation that needs to be
investigated they don't have to have a
complaint so if you if you wish to look
at the overriding laws relating to the
conduct of counsellors the conduct
complaints that may come forward or not
that doesn't have to be specifically a
complaint so please do not be under the
misapprehension that you need to write a
letter to make a complaint about
somebody if the standards of this
council are not upheld
in the way in which the monitoring
officer believes they should be then
they can investigate and take that
forward so that's an incorrect
assumption can we move on please
chairman
can we move on to the vote please
um
one brief comment cancellation you
haven't spoken but then then we're going
to take the vote
council eden
okay
cancer eden
um yes i i just wanted to follow up on
that point from our managing director
that in fact my experience of that is is
quite the opposite and i've got an email
trail that shows various monitoring
officers telling me that i have to put
in a form rather than inform them um
either verbally or through an email so
perhaps this perhaps the
system has changed mr shares but i can
actually prove that that is not what has
happened in the past
right i would say we did have a motion
to defer we will go to that vote first
before we go to the main vote so there
was a motion put forward by councillor
parker khan and i think it was seconded
by
councillor patch so
do can we have a vote please on the
matter being deferred
keep hands up please
those okay those against deferment
so that item is lost
now we go to the the main vote which was
to
um as per the original recommendation
which was seconded by councillor
bulovant for this to go forward as it
stands
all those in favor
recorded vote
councillor austin
councillor bradford
chancellor bulevant
councilman clarence
councillor colclough
councillor connect
councillor cook
councillor david
cox councillor hugh cox
councillor dawes
councillor dewhurst
councillor eden
cancer goodman bradbury
councillor gribble
councillor haynes
councillor hayes
council hocking
councillor gordon hook
cancer jackie hook
councillor jeffrey
cancer jeffries
councillor keeling
councillor kurzweil
council mcgregor
councilor morgan
councilman malone
natalie
councillor nuttall
councillor orm
cancer parker khan
councillor patch
councillor phipps
council persa
councillor russell
cancer swain
councillor taylor
councillor thorne
councillor wrigley
councillor evans
councillor parker four
that is carried and it goes forward as
stands
thank you very much councillors
we'll now move on to item nine which is
another recommendation from the
procedures committee and the standard
subcommittee
and it's recommended to full council
that
one the council's procedural rules
should be amended so that councillors
serving on the planning committee are no
longer permitted to vote on applications
within their ward
two
motions to approve refuse
defer plan allocation should be made at
the end of a debate on the application
which would allow any questions raised
during debate to be answered
three
all counsellors be reminded that the
deadline for submission of new
evidence information on planning
application being considered by planning
committee is midnight thursday prior to
the meeting and no later and four
any new information or submissions
regarding planning applications should
be submitted to the planning email
address by midnight thursday prior to
the meeting now what i do propose is to
take each one of these individually so
um
i would recommend that this be put
forward as a block but i would like
individual comments on each item
so item one
cancer counselor morgan
thank you thank you chair i would also
like these to be taken individually
because i have a very deep seated
problem with item one
just because a councillor is elected to
award does not mean that they cannot be
objective
about a planning application and to say
otherwise is um
it's unfair it's pretty judgmental
already
it's not up to the council to determine
whether a councillor has a conflict of
interest on a planning application it is
up to the individual
perhaps what we need to be looking at if
there are issues around this is a more
robust training system
all councillors are received statutory
training before taking part in planning
committees perhaps if this is
turning out to be a problem perhaps the
training needs to be addressed
i cannot support
item one i find it rather authoritarian
and somewhat illiberal
thank you council morgan councillor
malone
yeah part one if pastor is going to make
it impossible for members of the
planning committee to i can't read to
vote on anything in their own ward even
if they have no pecuniary interest and
there's no personal advantage to the
vote going one way or another
um as you know nsn was formed to fight a
single local issue on environmental
grounds we've had to fight each time to
keep our single vote on planning and
prove that janet has no financial stake
in the outcome
lovers hate us or really hate us we were
elected by people who wanted a voice on
the planning decisions where they live
and that's what local democracy is for
people electing people to represent
their communities and counter the
challenges that they perceive coming
against them in the age of biodiversity
collapse and climate change most of
these challenges will come from
development via planning now if past
this is going to disenfranchise anyone
concerned about a local issue a beauty
spot a daycare center a cinema a bypass
they won't be able to organize and seek
a mandated election because there won't
be any point any advocate for them will
be left voiceless simply because they
live in the place the project is
scheduled for now as annoying as we may
have been for the executive have we
really pushed you so far that you want
to disenfranchise entire communities and
gag their representatives because we've
had our struggles with the previous tory
administration of tdc on planning
matters you know that they rode
roughshod over what people wanted
shrugged at petitions and said so what
but they never came to the chamber and
set about cynically dismantling the
voice of local people and their
representatives just to give themselves
a slightly easier ride
there's no argument about legal exposure
in conflicts of interest cases because
the localism act 2011 chapter 6 section
25 is written to specifically avoid any
possibility of legal challenge based on
predetermination so there's absolutely
no need for this item
thank you
thank you councilman
councillor wrigley
uh thank you chair i fully support many
of the comments come forward already i
don't agree with any of these proposals
in this entire
piece i'm afraid and will be voting
against all of them
particularly as as a liberal democrat i
fundamentally believe that decisions
should be made as close to those
affected as possible that's why i'm
proud that we've enabled town councils
to have more of a say in the planning
process
our hands are tied by the planning
process all right already to a huge
extent and the system is very much
geared up in favor of the developers we
have to carry on enabling the local ward
members to be the voice of their
community now i'm not on the planning
committee this doesn't impact me but
definitely do not think we should take
away the participation of the um of the
local member in voting on that planning
committee
i understand why this was put together
but this is a bit like the famous
dangerous dogs act where a knee-jerk
reaction was taken in parliament which
gave us an unworkable situation because
of a problem that was perceived to have
happened
this is not the right answer to the
problem
yes we can make improvements to our the
way we run our planning committee yes
there are things that can be done better
no i don't think this is the right
answer i personally will be voting
against all four of these and i urge my
colleagues to do the same
council swain
i can see that these proposals come from
a sensible place i think a point
nobody's made is that this might be
viewed as protecting the members from
contentious decisions um
but i am still against it i'm afraid um
we come from a three-seat ward um in ken
valley and because we don't have
proportional representation all three of
those seats are held by liberal
democrats um i'd be the first to agree
that's not fair and i campaign against
it but in the planning committee we do
have proportional representation we've
got political balance across the
committees uh it would be perfectly
possible that all three ken valley
councillors would be on the planning
committee
which would be proportionally balanced
and then every single planning
application that came up for grand
valley three members would be removed
from the decision all from one party
that wouldn't be fair thank you
councillor patch
thank you yes um as has been pointed out
this strikes to the heart of local
representation if if locally elected
representatives of communities cannot
exercise a vote having taken into
account all the material considerations
and the arguments for and against then a
big link is cut between the
representational power of that member
and and their ability to sort of
represent the views of their communities
um
i don't see that there's a need for this
i know where this is coming from um i
believe we will talk about the
the the rest of the um items two three
and four after this but so i'll just
finally say on this item who will
benefit from this it's likely to be
developers i would think um
now there's a certain party that um gets
a lot of flack for being the developer's
friend and writing developers charters
i think we all need to think about where
this is coming from and what the
implications are
counselor mcgregor
thank you chair um
i've chosen to speak speak against this
motion i'm um
going to cover some of the the elements
behind my
uh reason for speaking against the four
points specifically
on the 6th of july the standards
committee
subcommittee met president of that
meeting with councillors conor purt and
councillor pedrick's chair
as a deputy monitoring officer president
but notice the council solicitor wasn't
there nor the other qualified legal
person
the hearing was convened to hear a
complaint about pre-determination
against councillor patch
the nature of the complaint being heard
at standards was a considerable surprise
to me because
predetermination is a civil law matter
not a standards matter
and as such should have been heard
either through the planning inspector
its appeal process or should have been
heard in judicial review
this then brought these recommendations
and there is no indication as to where
these recommendations were authored so
who actually decided on these
recommendations coming forward
predetermination
has not been found at this council since
its inception against any member
that's a clear case of a
procedure being
implemented to deal with something that
hasn't existed so far
predis predisposition is not the same as
predetermination it has to be said
um in terms of the
actual
first motion uh that counselors cannot
serve on the committee and vote on
matters in their own ward
um how does that how does that
deal with counselors who live in a
different ward
but also are going to be impacted are
they also going to be restricted from
voting on planning
so where councillor eden for instance is
in timothy central and the planning
application comes up there and i'm also
living in tinman central and planning
application the same planning
application am i therefore
then
able to vote or not because that has a
direct impact on me i have there's a
direct
potential influence for me so
it's unclear as a process in that
instance a situation where a counselor
lives in a different ward and has an
application and that would then
therefore indicate
an inconsistent approach at best
the other points i'll i'll cover those
individually as i come through them but
what i would like to say is
this is a solution for a problem that
does not exist
it's a solution that treats us like
children
a solution that that roads local
democracy and a solution delivered in my
view under dubious circumstances
before i moved to reject this first
motion
i would like to thank the contribution
from david cox in respect to pointing me
to the past probity matter and the fact
that predetermination is a civil law
matter and in a words not the competence
of the authority
i would move that at least this first
one is rejected
and if there's a second uh then perhaps
after the rest of the debate
thank you council mcgregor council of
connie
uh thank you chairman i would say these
recommendations are an example actually
of our constitution working and
democracy in action so let's just look
at where they come from
they are recommendations by the standard
subcommittee and as simply mentioned
that was me councillor
and cancer patrick having dealt with a
matter before the standard subcommittee
then decided to take it further and say
maybe there's a case here for council to
consider these matters
and it made a recommendation to the
procedures committee who considered it
further
and then make a recommendation to
council
that is a good process it says look
something was brought to us about of a
concern we want to share that with you
we want the council to decide whether
for example it wants to change the rule
so that members on the planning
committee don't have a vote or you keep
your vote so the conversation which has
been about or the executive want to
close people up well this isn't from the
executive it's from a standard
subcommittee via procedures to council
it's a conversation about whether you
say the vote for a member on the
planning committee in the on an
application an award
takes a priority over for example the
risk of the pressure applied to a
counsellor or being seen to somehow sort
of favor one side or another now
i should be voting in favor of one uh
because i think actually on balance and
for me it's a fine judgment call but on
balance i think that's the right thing
to do but i fully respect the desire of
counsellors to say no if i'm on planning
i want to vote on all matters and
including those in my world perfectly
fine understandable i don't have an
argument about it but i do think it's
right that our constitution and the way
this has worked is brought it to you for
conversation and discussion today at
this meeting and i'm rather surprised
given some of the earlier debate about
let's have a constitution let's talk
about it something why are we talking
about this now this is outrageous who
put this on the agenda this shouldn't be
allowed this is immoral this shouldn't
be going on when actually it's down to
you as members to decide and it's come
from the right place in the right way
for your consideration and if you're for
it that's fine and if you're against it
that's perfectly fine too you know it's
about you deciding what your
constitution is and what it will be
thank you
thank you cancer hook
hi thank you um
yeah i'd like to um also agree with much
of what's been said but in particular i
wanted to agree with the first comments
made by councillor morgan um the
implication of what is being recommended
is that councillors cannot be objective
about some applications in their own
ward
i've been on planning committee since
2011 our duty at the planning committee
is to consider the interests of the
wider district in the round when we
consider applications i'd like to think
i always do that i like the fact that
we've made votes publicly available so
that we have to explain the decision
we've made to the public and i like to
think i and i hope every other planning
committee member would be able to
explain to the public why they voted the
way they did even though sometimes
we we're faced with the most incredibly
difficult decisions where really we've
only got two two decisions a bad
decision and to make it or worse
decision and we have to choose between
them
it's a very difficult committee the
decisions we make are difficult i'd like
to think i could always explain it
and always be objective
if a counselor has an interest which
means they're not able to do that then
they need to declare it as has been
stated but we shouldn't take away the
right of counsellors to vote on
applications in their own ward thank you
thank you
thank you council councillor relevant
thank you
item one here is a very difficult uh
question to answer
in terms of looking at the structure
of the planning committee
the committee is there as councillor
hook has just said to represent the
wider interests of the hundred and
thirty odd thousand people of teen
bridge
however it's also a fact that with 17
members on that committee that means
there's 30 councillors who already do
not have a voice anyway or a vote
every councillor has a voice every
counselor has the option of attending a
committee meeting of the planning
committee to present
an argument one way or the other
in favor or against a particular
application
so that voice is always there to be
heard
it's up to the counselor to make his
voice heard in those circumstances
but the issue for me here is not that
it's
it's increasingly seeing
a seek to question the integrity of
councillors
and to me
there are council well there are 47
councils in this room and their
integrity i respect
and i think in this case we should
respect the integrity of our councillors
we shouldn't put in front of them
barriers to prevent them representing
through a vote
and for that reason i'm afraid in terms
of question one i have a great
difficulty in
uh supporting
removing a counsellor because of a
particular location where they represent
thank you
thank you councilman councillor gribble
thank you chairman
um i i think the local towns and
parishes the constituents there
represent
for us to represent councillors to
represent their their their towns and
parishes thank you sir
thank you councillor clarence
up the front
i've enjoyed being on the planning
committee since 2003 when i was first
elected here and
i i always
proud to vote the way i do for
applications in our ward and i wouldn't
wouldn't want to see that taken away
from me i think local
people need to know the way you voted
about which and what and you know that's
how i feel i'm agreeing i think with
majority of the room here almost we'll
see what happens at the vote thank you
councillor parker khan
thank you chair a lot of people have
passed and i was only going to say i
find myself surprisingly agreeing with
councilman mcgregor on this one um i
think everything's been said i think it
removes uh ability to
put forward our point of view as a
council that represents the ward
and we have a mechanism in place for us
to be able to
declare an interest so that you don't
vote where necessary so i think this
potentially is a sledgehammer to crack
or not and and it might be useful to
vote soon
i think i agree councillor pat you've
got your hand up i know it's been up for
a minute
yeah um sorry just to say um chair in
the event that it's not a univ
unit yeah that we all don't vote the
same way when we vote by share of hand
can we have a recorded vote if it's not
unanimous
um
and i'd ask for those to support that to
raise their hands
i think we have enough for that
yep that's fine okay
i'm just going to pass over to managing
director for a moment
thank you chairman totally understand
members views it this wasn't officers
bringing forward these set of
recommendations this was certainly
something that was from the
uh standards and the procedures
committees
just just for your knowledge
we as officers and uh the planning
department and legal would support two
three and four because we think that's a
tidying up and will protect you going
forward totally recognize what council
mcgregor has said
however with the more litigious society
we're living in and the challenges that
you're facing it would make a sensible
tidying up in terms of making evidence
available on the website earlier
getting applicants and
objectives to be able to see that
because that could be both sides uh and
also in terms of the motions and uh
whether you're going to recommend
approval
or
rejection of that planning application
doing that at the end of the debate
rather than asking questions during it
and then making a statement at the end
of your your
speech
before people have a chance to either
respond to that or others to hear it and
debate those issues so
totally understand if where you where
you may wish to go with one
but two three and four would just ask
for your consideration because we think
that would protect you as a councillor
planning department better going
forwards because it wasn't um an ideal
scenario we think going forward and i
think that would make a a sensible uh
policy to bring in but thank you
chairman
councillor dawes did you have your
i uh yes i'd agree with what uh many
people have said that it's a following a
un democratic and unrepresentative trend
uh the point two seems to make no sense
at all uh that you have motions at the
end of the debate because surely you
have emotion and then debate and talk
speak to the motion i thought that's
what democracy uh asked for
uh equally 0.3 seems to uh be stuck in
some sort of uh
weekly time war that the meeting has to
be on a certain day it doesn't actually
say what day the meeting's on it should
sensibly if it was uh to be voted on i'd
vote against it but say a number of days
rather than a thursday
uh and i was going to suggest it was a
recorded vote but it it is indeed thank
you
councillor kerr as well and it's uh nice
to see you here councillor kurzweil
thank you chairman um i've been on the
town council planning committee since
2000 and i've been on team ridge
district council planning committee
since i came on about eight years ago
um i feel that
my integrity has never been questioned
i do represent my community but i also
do represent team bridge in the round
and i will continue to do that
for as long as i serve on on team bridge
district council
i agree with everything that my
colleagues have said here this morning
and
i shall not be voting for item one
thank you
thank you councillor coswell cancer
connie
um
chairman i'm very mindful of all of the
comments received from colleagues and
i'm thinking without regard to item one
in order to save a bit of time on a
recorded vote
would would council agree to item one
simply being withdrawn
and if it's withdrawn that's the end of
the matter
are counselors happy with that that it
is withdrawn because all the comments
seem to be to that effect
happy to second that yes
i think everyone is happy with that
situation so
right did you want to make a comment
counselor really just
we ought to have a name tag didn't
everybody so we know where the
microphone has to go um firstly i'd like
to sort of thank the standards committee
and the procedures committee of bringing
this forward and as council o'connor
says it's right that we debate it um i
was going to second uh council
mcgregor's motion which i don't think
was second that this was voted on uh
this was rejected i think i'd prefer to
see it rejected rather than withdrawn
because once it's rejected it's gone if
it's withdrawn it can come back again
well there was a proposal have it with
withdrawn i mean uh if anyone would like
to second that is withdrawn
chair we have a proposal that was made
and seconded first which i think we
should vote on before a new proposal
okay that proposed awesome councillor
mcgregor
right would you like to repeat
councilman
briefly
um
my view is that this is a solution
without a problem and as such i would
recommend that we withdraw i sorry
reject this uh particular aspect point
number one okay point number this is
point number one and that was seconded
by councillor wrigley okay um shall we
go to the vote
and we wanted a recorded delivery
recorded vote and recorded delivery very
good
recorded vote
councillor austin
councillor bradford
councillor bill event councillor
clarence
cancer cochlear
council of connets
councillor cook
councillor cook
cancer david cox
councillor hugh cox
councillor dawes
councillor dewhurst
councillor eden
council goodman bradbury
councilor gribble
councillor haynes
cancer hayes
council hocking
cancer gordon hook
cancer jackie hook
counselor jeffrey
councillor jefferies
councillor keeling
cancer care as well
councillor mcgregor
councillor morgan
councilman malone
councilman natalie
cancer nuttel
cancer parker calm
cancer patch
cancer phipps
counselor persa
councillor russell
councillor swain
councillor taylor
cancer thorne
cancer
wrigley councillor evans
councillor parker
abstain
right
cancer doors has your hand up
hi i've got a point of order could we
please have a comfort break
yes i was just going to mention that
situation
what i'd like to be able to do is to
complete this item if we could before we
have a comfort break if that's okay i
think a lot of the comments have been
made in respect of
items two three and four
i'm sorry i i really want to vote on
this item but i i'd like a comfort break
now thank you
i i think we we will go with that we've
gone on a bit longer so i'll say that
we'll have a comfort break at this time
this will be 10 minutes
welcome back councillors
i hope that suitably refreshed you
thank you
right uh we're on
item nine
part two
um
what i'm going to suggest if unless
people have got additional comments on
each
item which i'm happy to take
we will go to
votes
on each one in turn
unless anyone has any comments on each
individual which a few have already
okay
right okay then we'll go to part two
if i got anyone who would like to speak
on part two um yeah counselor wrigley
was the first one looks like it
thank you chair now i can understand
why
something might be done about the form
of the debate but i think councillor
doors already raised
the standards the rules of debate are
set out in the constitution
say you have a proposal then you have a
discussion you debate the proposal you
cannot have a debate unless you have a
proposal
so what's laid out here is actually
against the constitution that we've just
reaffirmed as far as i can work out
i wouldn't go against thinking about
whether we separate the questions to the
officer so we can improbe for
information first and then have a debate
that might be a workable solution
but i think what's written here will
cause confusion and will not be as
useful as the current debates are so i
would be voting against this for that
reason
sorry i propose refusal of this for that
reason okay noted country mcgregor
thank you jay uh like councillor wrigley
i i have similar views on on the debate
process but also would also like to
suggest that on occasion for instance on
a deferral
sometimes a planning application has
come
with last minute changes
which are significant and therefore
the debate really can't be held
effectively because of that information
and i would second that um motion of of
uh
councillor wrigley
noted thank you councillor patch
thank you um yep well notwithstanding uh
mr shear's warm words in support of two
three and four i'd like to submit i
think they're all a nonsense
as it's been pointed out number two is
contrary to the constitution and in fact
the way that debates work in terms of
talking to emotion um parts three and
parts four do not take um into account
what would happen with the information
arising after that deadline um what does
it does it disappear into the void is it
not considered um and also as as i
believe um councillor dawes or what
other members has pointed out what about
if meetings are playing me to move to
another day then reference to thursday
does not really make any sense
in terms of the item two and
the timing of motions the administration
of um
proposals for against um my mind's drawn
back to a planning training meeting not
the last one we had but the previous one
where we had a very experienced um
planning consultant taking our planning
training who mentioned what other
authorities do in addressing this issue
of motions for or against early in a
debate and he he suggested that team
bridge consider having a starting
position of working with the motion um
or the recommendations of the officer
which would then remove this issue of
who makes the proposal
i would think um that would be certainly
something
worth considering rather than this which
is contrary to the constitution um i i
hear about proposes put forward to
reject item two i would say based on the
the nonsensical nature of the of the
three and four i would like to move on
block that we vote
to reject two three and four
councillor morgan
um yep thank you um item two is a one
size fits all item it doesn't consider
the individual nature at each
application that comes forward and it
would also stifle debate for example
we may decide we may realize very
quickly on um in the uh officer's uh
presentation
that this is not this is contentious
this needs a site visit in which case
you need to decide to defer straight
away so it stifles debate it's it's a
one size fits all item uh
i'm not on the planning committee here
but i'm on dartmouth national park we
start from the office's recommendation
as the debate point
there and that seems to work extremely
well and then members can add in
a proposal as the debate proceeds
items three and four
i had mixed feelings about this because
hopefully it would also apply to
developers with last minute information
as well as objectives however
for
significant and complex applications
there may be late submissions regarding
ecology reports there may be changes in
government
bills or legislation that would have an
effect on this and these do seem to
happen overnight at the moment
so i i would like to second uh
councillor patch's um proposal that we
reject all of these on block
noted cancel them alone
thank you i think the nub of this item
is uh not pass or reject but the but
they would defer um the planning
proposals will only be deferred after
they've been thoroughly discussed of
course it's human nature not to want to
bend something after three hours of back
and forth just have to do the same thing
again in two months this is an attempt
to get more things passed but through
exhaustion through cynicism through the
simple fact that we'd all like to have a
family life and notwithstanding the uh
changes to the working hours that are
being pushed on us
so
so it's going to
get past because we're all exhausted
and feeling cynical about the motion
rather than looking at each proposal
clearly and on its own merits um if this
is passed then frankly i don't think
anything will be deferred anymore even
when there's evidence and key facts
missing
thank you councillor haynes did you have
your hand up cancer haynes
thank you chairman um well i have
observed other planning committees from
time to time
excuse me um
due to the work i've done related to an
earlier item we were discussing
some planning committees
do have questions before they actually
then go into the debate and i know
that's what i think council wrigley
was initially hinting at so i think that
would be
although it's not before us now that
would be a useful way of looking at how
this this could be dealt with at some
future time
others are definitely
of the same
view as what's expressed here and at the
end of the day it's it's looking at the
the issue of predetermination that's how
it got here today it's something that
came from standards committee because of
the the perception by the public that um
it's predetermined when somebody
proposes something right at the outset
before perhaps questions
have been answered so on on two whilst i
understand what members are saying
i feel that there ought to be we ought
to look at the opportunity for questions
before emotions put
so for that reason i i'm obviously happy
to go along with it not being carried in
that form today
the other two are to make sure that
members of the committee have got all
the information before them in good time
and i think it was um councillor morgan
talked about things being sprung you
know very much at the last minute we
want to avoid that so that members have
had the chance to look at any
information and then be able to
assimilate that as part of their
decision-making process so
that for that reason i can see why the
the other two are being suggested
that it should form part of our practice
and essentially it does in in the sense
that things coming in
go on to the late representations
sheet which members then get and which
is published a day before committee in
order that members do get this late
information so at the end of the day the
whole point is to try and make it that
members are not perceived to be
predetermined and that they have all the
information available for them
so they can make a decision thank you
thank you councillor haines councillor
hook
thanks jay i think the the problem with
three and four
is that they're time specific nobody's
actually said that this is to allow
officers to respond or
members to familiarize themselves the
illusion or the
intention i'm sure has been there but
i i can't support three and four
while
well it is time specific if we're going
to talk about thursday midnight that's
making the assumption i think that the
planning committees are held on the
monday or the tuesday allowing a certain
time frame of for consideration
either
these need to be rewritten if they're
going to be accepted i believe and
therefore i shall be able to vote for
them in their current form if if we were
to say
uh midnight on thursday
assuming that planning is held on the
tuesday morning let's say that that
might be possible but as things stand
this is very unclear um and needs to be
rewritten removed and rewritten thank
you
councillor cox
you did put your hand up councillor cox
i was just going to say i was going to
propose that we differ
reference back to the procedures
committee because there are some good
ideas here and rather than throw them
out completely they could be re-uh done
i like the i like the question idea
suggested by councillor uh ridley that
that would that would seem to solve that
problem okay
councillor malone
um councillor haynes is referring to uh
concerns of the public over
predetermination i think that's another
one of our ghosts isn't it and it's not
yet halloween it's uh
there has been no such concerns
expressed by the public what he's
referring to is a complaint by uh
the owner of trego mills who didn't get
a vote going the way he wanted that is
an entirely different
subject and it doesn't inform what we're
talking about here
cancer oblivion
thank you in terms of
item two on the list here
the
principle being discussed really relates
to the training that people had when
they were first appointed to the
committee
and basically the point about
predetermination was made very very
clear as part of that training
i'm surprised it's being raised now as a
uh as a question
it's very clear that councillors sitting
on the planning committee are there to
represent and hear all views before
reaching a conclusion and in that case
what's asked for here is that that is
legitimized in terms of not being in a
position to declare a position
before all points of view have been
considered and expressed
and in that regard i think this is a
sensible adaption or adulteration to our
procedures
thank you
thank you councillor connect
thanks chairman with regard to two
um i remember there was a discussion
about whether
uh you should start the starting point
it should be that the officer
recommendation is the one if you like
that is automatically seconded that is
the
the recommendation before the committee
and we felt uh in our discussions as
your members might not like that because
it might imply that the officers somehow
were dictating the debate of the
conversation so the idea was actually
not to do that to do something different
um
and
in terms of it where we're at now i was
interested to hear what the practice is
at dartmouth national park which is to
work on the basis of the recommendation
that forms the
the discussion
uh because
here in team bridge
we all know what the game is the officer
recommendation is there and if you are
wanting to propose refusal or
approval contrary to what the officer
recommendation is you need to you know
you need to get in quick make that
recommendation and get one of your
planning committee colleagues to to
second it and that then becomes the
substantive motion
the problem with that is that for
members of the public uh whether they
are in the chamber or viewing online
they may not know that and so you say uh
you know chairman uh i move refusal i
move approval someone else quick jumps
in to say seconded
he then set out the reason why you're
saying that
and that's fine isn't it except that a
debate then follows on that
but you've already declared your hand
and might that look as though you were
predetermined because immediately the
debate had started you said that so it
was from again from a good place to try
and actually make sure councillors could
debate could ask questions could
inquire of planning offices highways
officers whoever else there is you have
the debate and then you make a
recommendation which might be the office
of recommendation it might be something
different again if members feel that the
current practice that cambridge
has is fit and proper for purpose that's
perfectly fine we've heard that
dartmouth national park do something
slightly different
it's about trying to learn from others
and trying to put ourselves in a good
place
i wasn't referring to any particular
issue about planning members or a
planning application it was about the
standards committee or the subcommittee
and procedures again saying to members
do you want to look at this
don't think there's time in merit for a
change if you do that's good and if you
don't that's perfectly fine as well it's
it's your planning committee and your
set of rules um
in terms of three and four uh i think i
probably put my hand up to the guilt of
simplicity being the enemy of clarity
our meetings are on a tuesday or
whatever day of the week they are and so
thursday prior was seemed to be easier
to say
you're right if planning was on a
thursday or a friday we would have to
change it um
and to that respect if if
people feel that it should be that
specific then we should take three and
four back and come back with something
more appropriately worded that that fits
in with a you know non-specific day of
the week for the planning committee um
and i i think three and four reference
back would be easier if people are
minded to understand what we're trying
to do is make sure all of the members
have all of the information available
and there are no late submissions that
someone frankly says you know 50 pages
of additional information were emailed
out to me on a sunday night for a
planning committee on a monday morning
i've not had a chance to read it uh
whereas trying to so this again three
and four are about trying to assist
members rather than hinder them but your
decisions thank you
thank you council connor councillor
haynes did you wanted to come back
thank you chairman it was just a
personal explanation since i was named
the comments i made related to those
that i've experienced across the country
in terms of the public perception and
indeed other other ones over the years
at team bridge i wasn't making reference
to any specific
case that went to the planning committee
other than the fact that this reference
came from the standards committee
can i say i think councillor cox
moved reference back i'm not sure if it
was seconded if it was uh if it's sorry
if it wasn't and i wish to second it for
the three items
that's back to the procedures committee
um
councillor wrigley
thank you thank you i think councillor
haynes has just done what i was trying
to do which was to second councillor con
it's uh refer back three and four
uh so i think that that's very much the
sensible way to go forward with that
uh so councillor cox wanted two three
and four i'm supporting councillor
connor on referring back three and four
second in cancer connect okay country
mcgregor
yes i know about the throw coming there
in a minute cancer patch
thank you chair um i just want to point
out that that um points one and two are
very different to points three and four
in that points one of two are actual
motions and point uh three and four are
recommendations about um
members are advised on procedure um
in terms of of
three floor we know we know there are
deadlines um developers also know there
are deadlines and sometimes in for
instance a recent
application
a developer dumped hundreds of pages of
of uh changes and amendments onto the
portal just before
it closed off and then we had a planning
meeting the following tuesday
the right thing to do was to move move
immediately to to defer
so that those could be properly
investigated so you know as councilor
morgan says what we're trying to do here
is a one-size-fits-all and in a
situation where we get
developers exploiting
their ability to to massively
exploit the the planning portal in the
deadlines
to the detriment of councillors and
residents who are objectors then we
would be failing in our duty
if we then proceeded to debate and i'm
absolutely convinced you know i know
council haynes is very patient man that
he would not allow us to debate every
item of information
in a case where hundreds of pages are
dumped because it is very technical and
a lot of expertise is particularly
needed from planning officers as well in
assessing that information
so from my perspective it's a
one-size-fits-all now i would
definitely definitely move to go that we
go to the vote on this now on the first
option which is to reject two
and then go to the second option which
is to reject uh to refer back three and
four which was councillor connor's uh
uh motion and seconded by councillor
wrigley
thank you mr mcgregor we seem to have a
variety of ways forward here um
councillor patch is that what you put
your hand up for to refer to that
well no i i think i think you recognize
that point chair um i just wanted to
refer back to on on a couple of
occasions well i think more than two at
least three times references we made to
the origins of these recommendations
being a standard case that was brought
against me i'd just like to put forward
my view that this was a deeply flawed
investigation that resulted in a deeply
flawed decision notices
thinking about what
addressing these issues
now if this council had received a
formal complaint
of of planning procedures the way
they're operated the role of officers um
including planning and legal officers in
administration of a planning decision um
even amounting to claims of systemic
failure at the council would we expect
the council to carry out some kind of
review of um planning procedures which
which might get to the depth of issues
that are to be investigated now i asked
that question if it's a hypothetical
question
i don't think it's proper that i say
whether that's happened or not um but i
i just would like to question
the origin of these recommendations and
to my mind there has not been a full
consideration of the issues that have
been put forward as problematic in team
bridge regarding planning and and that
there's not a link between that and
these recommendations that have come
forward
thank you cancer patch i don't know if
there's anyone else i've missed
obviously not no no you did put forward
a recommendation i think was seconded by
councillor morgan which was to vote on
block on all
items two three and four
was that
that was it
thank you chair i think i made the first
proposal that was then seconded by
council mcgregor could you just briefly
repeat that again which was to reject
item number two reject item two right
we'll go to the vote on item number two
to reject
okay
my my recommendation was to reject on
block two three four
sorry
apologies i will go with councillor
wrigley's at this time so to reject item
two seconded by councillor mcgregor all
those in favor to reject item two
if you're happy to do it by hand
against
abstain
that's carried right so that's item two
not gone through
uh so we're now
to the next items three and four i think
we had a
thing from councillor connect which was
to refer back three and four to
procedures
seconded by
councillor wrigley
can we go to the vote please all those
in favor that refer it back
against
abstentions
none that's that's carried both that's
carried so
so items three and four are referred
back to the procedures committee
thank you very much now we'll move on
and i'd like now to go to
item 12
which is an initial
presentation from the executive member
for corporate resources councillor
kailing
this is just the initial before we go
into part two explanation of the bradley
lane regeneration councilor keeling
thank you mr chairman
colleagues before we go to part two for
exempt finance financial information i
would like to thank all those officers
who have been involved in the
regeneration project of a brownfield
site
especially tom butcher lead officer and
neil blaney head of place and commercial
services
i would also with the chairman's
permission like to say a few words in
the public domain
this proposal offers
delivery on all our council priorities
for homes jobs and tackling climate
change the offer also proposes a mix of
property sizes to meet local needs with
smaller properties for first-time buyers
and downsizers alike
the affordable housing offer is more
than the policy requirements in newton
abbott
and as a landowner we have a proposal
that will secure best financial value
for the taxpayer
and given us
and give us a capital receipt that could
be invested into future projects
this is a sustainable location in many
ways with easy access to the town centre
excellent walking and cycling routes it
will comply with carbon reduction
targets as a minimum and will increase
flood capacity with the improvements to
the river lemon corridor
the council has undertaken a rigorous
procurement exercise over the last two
years to get us to the recommendation
before councillors a scheme that
achieves the briefing agreed by the
executive in 2019
members are being asked to consider this
proposal as the landowner of this site
the briefing last monday to all
councillors newton abbott town
councillors and partners was cut short
by the impending overview and scrutiny
one
but i can assure councillors that
subject to an approval there will be
full questions and answers session
giving more details in the october
november
again to district councillors town
councillors and partners
subject to agreement of the offer the
developer will need to secure planning
permission
which members will be able to consider
and detail and design details of the
proposal of the land of the local
planning authority
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much councillor keeling
right now then item 13 i would like to
recommend at this time
that under section 100a
brackets 4 of the local government act
1972 the press and public be excluded
from the meeting for the following items
on the grounds that they involve likely
disclosure of exempt information as
divined in paragraphs one two and three
of the part one of the 12a schedule 12a
of the act i so move can i have a second
to do that please thank you councillor
mcgregor
and i'm just waiting for confirmation
that live streaming has been cut
um
now on to item 10
which is notices of motion
and the first one i'd like to come to um
is councillor mcgregor
uh you'd like to present your notice
emotion uh thank you chair um what i
will say is that it's there for
everybody to read it's also on the on
the website but um
this this um particular motion was
penned some time ago um i was unable to
attend the full council meeting it was
supposed to be out originally
because i had better things to do the
following day and had some preparations
to make
um
[Music]
in real terms the the there are some
changes to government policy and
direction that have been evident over
the last period of time
um i think the the actual motion itself
the elements that we're asking for are
still relevant uh but there are
additional
elements i was going to re-author it but
councillor connor
perhaps might have a different view and
a better way to to handle that process
but i would move that we we um do write
to the government and the various
ministers that are responsible
and particularly around the last point
on the actual substantive motion which
is to reintroduce the ban on near
nicotinides that actually hasn't
been
um revoked as a use but emergency
derogations are continuing to be granted
to
agricultural sector
to
use neonicotinoids and that is an
absolute
element that we must stop as soon as
possible if we are to retain our ability
to produce the food that we want to have
high
import standards and high production
standards across the rest of the
sector so from my perspective you know i
would like to reintroduce the motion as
it stands at the moment but also perhaps
with council's permission come back with
some additional ones later yeah so
you're referring it
referring it to the
executive yeah okay
so the proposal to
move it to the executive to have a
secondary for that please cancel wrigley
um
all those in favor
against against
abstentions
fine thank you very much that's referred
to executive
uh we'll now move on to noise emotion
number two cancer eden if you'd like to
present this noticeable motion yes thank
you very much i'm going to be careful
how i pronounce this i'm going to talk
about ethics
not essex
because i have a professional life in as
a chair former chair of a national
health service ethics committee and a
professional life in informed consent
and worrying about how people make
decisions and undue influence and
importantly in declaring conflicts of
interest and it's my view that we need
to
clarify our current process in terms of
the definition of conflict of interest
and those of you who've had time to read
my uh the wording that's been supplied
will see that i'm referring back to the
charity commission in in terms of
actually suggesting that we define a
connected person as follows family
relatives business partners of a
councillor as well as businesses in
which a council has an interest through
ownership or influence and that term i
am proposing needs to include
counsellors spouses unmarried partners
civil partners so on children siblings
grandchildren and the most important
point i think i should make is this
a number of people have referred to
whether somebody has integrity or not
integrity it's not about that it's not a
binary thing the whole point about
declaring an interest or a conflict of
interest is understanding within
yourself whether something about the
proposal is linked to you in some way an
understanding that that is getting in
the way of your objectivity so i think
counselor bulova mentioned earlier on he
was concerned about you know accusations
of lack of integrity this shouldn't be
about that this is about understanding
conflict of interest
in relation to that just quickly
sound effects of turning paper i'm also
interested i really want to push forward
a further clarity over what we mean in
terms of conflict of loyalty in turning
in terms of our registry of interests
and i'm aware that at the county council
members are required for example to
notify their membership the freemasons
and i think tdc should do the same as
well i think they should be aligned so
that's those are the main points i
wanted to make and just to really say we
should always all of us be asking
ourselves are we biased and not not
asking ourselves am i have i got
integrity or not because that's not the
issue at hand thank you
thank you country and is this something
they would like to bait it at this time
because if you do we need two-thirds of
us here to be donated or would you like
to refer it
i'd love to debate it but it's been a
long morning and i think it will be
cruel to suggest that so i'm happy to
refer it happy to refer to standards
right the proposes to refer it to
standards second for that please council
mcgregor all those in favor
all against any against
abstentions
one abstention
fine thank you
that's
referred to standards um motion three
council eden again your
motion for promotion 3 please
thank you thanks very much
um
right so i'm very keen that we get more
transparency for the public in terms of
what happens after an application has
gone into planning because we all know
that what happens the application goes
in it's passed and then somehow all
sorts of variations seem to occur and
those variations don't seem to come back
to planning and they don't have any
scrutiny and i think the public have a
right to see a due process over the over
a situation where for example a
developer has promised a certain number
of affordable homes or street art or
various aspects of their development
which suddenly magically don't happen
and there's nothing we can do about it
well i think what we can do about it as
a start is make sure people know what's
happening so i'm proposing that we
require that we require developers to
come back to planning and actually
explain and propose any uh variations
they are seeking to achieve
yes
thank you very much
now
councillors are we happy to refer this
to procedures committee for discussion
are you happy with that counselor eden
or do you want this debated
two thirds
again i love a good debate but i can see
people are a bit jaded and yes referring
back is absolutely fine thank you we
have a proposal a secondary to refer to
procedures
council russell
the question of viability because that
is one of the things that does come
forward when developed suddenly
developers want to change things
amid permission
and development they they complain about
lack of
viability so that needs to be taken into
consideration as well are you happy yes
it's not of head i think that's quite
happy so with that slight amendment are
we all happy that this goes back to
procedures those
cancer client
microphone
chairman um the motion has set out has
been is being accepted and it's a
procedural matter which in terms of uh
bringing forward changes back to
planning so that's a prestigious
committee viability is a separate matter
altogether and is not within the
competence of the procedures committee
to advise on and in my view can the the
if there is a view about viability that
ought to be a matter of a separate
motion on a different days if that's the
issue or if it can't be dealt with
through the planning committee uh
process but my advice to cancers and to
cancer eden would be not to accept the
addition of liability it's not within
the competence of procedures to deal
with it
okay
are you with that council russell
then suddenly issues of viability do
rear their heads
uh within that and for instance can i
take out the uh
the requirement to provide a little
parade of shops or provide a residential
home all these sort of things tend to
come and they are
put towards being
non-viable
if a developer has to do that so i i
disagree with allen with here because it
does raise its head viability
and and that is taken as a reason for
not proceeding with parts of a
development
okay council mcgregor
i'll keep this as brief as possible um
you know and like with council russell
not often agreeing with council reading
i think this is possibly a first um i
believe that viability is an important
issue
i would however potentially look at it
in slightly different ways viability is
supposed to be assessed by the planning
officers before a planning application
comes to committee
um that's on according to the gov
dot uk website
um
the element of viability that then comes
back in is going to be handled through
the
variation coming to planning committee
if if it's past the procedures and then
pass by full council
it would that that explanation of why
it's suddenly no longer viable when the
planning application should have been
viable when it was passed anyway
and i think
you know the intent in uh councillor
motion is not to question the decision
of the planning officer in granting or
not granting uh condition change but to
actually have it explained to the public
so that it is completely transparent
that is something that counselor gordon
hook when he was leader and took up the
leadership of the administration
promised the people of team bridge and i
think it's really upon us as a as a
as a council as an executive as a
planning committee to ensure that we are
as transparent as we possibly can be
within the guidelines of the law
thank you okay councillor haines
just to point out chairman that
viability is mentioned in the motion
it's at the the sort of penultimate line
top of page seven so it is to be
considered when this ghost is referred
back
okay so the motion is as it stands
viability is already there and you're
happy with that counselor russell yes
okay well we will go to the vote on that
that it is referred to procedures then
all those in favor
okay against
abstentions
so that is referred to uh procedures
uh right councillor connect is now
presenting motion four
thank you chairman i formally move has
set out and also reference to the
executive for further consideration and
recommendation back to council thank you
well that's straightforward i'll second
that
all those in favor
okay
against
abstentions
okay thank you very much we're nearly
there counsellors
we're now on
item 11 which is basically for
information
i presume you've all read it it was just
about the decarbonisation of
the broad mental sports centre at
timmouth
and the urgent decision why this was
taken in july
just for note accounts council russell
agreed
thank you
right thank you very much councillors
officers thank you very much for a long
meeting
we've come to the end and
hopefully we'll see you again soon